(Please stand by.
The GOOGLE I/O 2018 session The
Web:
State of the Union will begin
shortly on Stage 2.)
(Music playing.
)
(The GOOGLE I/O 2018 session
The Web: State of the Union will
begin at the top of the hour.
Please stand by.
)
(The session The Web: State
of the
Union will begin in
approximately five minutes.
Please continue to stand by.
)
(The GOOGLE I/O 2018 session on
Stage
2, The Web: State of the Union,
will begin momentarily.
)
knowns welcome.  Thank you
for joining.  Our session will
begin soon.
(Music playing.
)
momentarily.)
>> ANNOUNCER: Welcome.
Thank you for joining.  Our
session will begin soon.
(Music playing.
)
>> ANNOUNCER: At this time,
please find your seat.  Our
session will begin soon.
(Music playing.
)
>>> good afternoon, everyone
and
welcome to the The Web: State of
the Union.
I'm Ben gallon brat.
>> MALTE UBL: And I'm Malte
Ubl.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: We are
going to highlight what we are
excited about.
>> MALTE UBL: We will talk
through
the latest libraries and
frameworks we are working on to
make you more productive.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: We have a
lot to cover in the session.
Let's dive right in.
>> MALTE UBL: Let's go.
All right.
>> MALTE UBL: The web has
special
meaning for us at Google because
the core froab.  We are making
it open and accessible to the
web.
It is important for us that the
web is healthy and driving.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: The web
significance canned significant
new APIs and capabilities.
>> MALTE UBL: Probably the
most
important API in the last ten
years is service worker.  Since
the beginning of the web it has
been about pagers the user
requests and the browser
rendered and we changed that to
top level abstraction that goes
beyond what a page can do,
receiving
events like push, handle, data
synchronization even after the
page went away.
You can make robust offline web
pages.
Service worker has been in a
good amount of browsers for
awhile but now they are
basically everywhere.
With Mac OS this Mayur and
microchip
worker last week put out every
single major modern browser
supports the standard.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: This is a
huge moment for the web and we
are excited about it.  We have
been using progressive web app
to explain the new improvements
and the gradual roll out of
service worker
illustrates the bit here.  PWAs
that are written progressively
to take advantage of browser
feeps as they are available can
seamlessly upgrade with no need
to redeploy.  PWAs are
everywhere.
I want to share a few examples.
Let's start with  OFO, global
bike sharing company which is
coming to the Bay area soon.
>> MALTE UBL: Another one, all
right.  Been you can never have
too many.
This uses the GPS to find the
camera all directly in the
browser.  That's it.  You can
start riding the bike.  I love
this  example.  It shows the
power of the web's low friction
model.  You skip all the steps
of finding an app in the store
and installing it.
So mother's day is coming up
next week.
>> MALTE UBL: Uh-oh.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: It makes 1800
flowers a good mention.
50 percent more of their
customers bought things after
they rolled out this app.
Let's take a look at editor
globo in Brazil.  They saw a 50
percent increase in
users time are spending on their
site.
>> MALTE UBL: Starbucks rolled
out the PWA and saw their daily
and monthly users double.
because in works well on
desktops, users can order from
their desk and
Google found this-e -- Starbucks
found
this is something users want
better than.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: Across all
sites
with Google we saw upgrading
with PWA delivers average 20
percent boost to the website
conversion rate.  That's 20
percent more people who wind
up  transacting on the site as a
result.
This PWA movement we have been
talking about is not just lip
service.
All modern web capabilities
deliver a materially better
experience and it shows up in
the bottom lune of the
businesses that we've all built
on the web.
>> MALTE UBL: All right, Ben,
since we are at Google I/O.
It would be a good time to talk
about
what Google itself is doing in
the PWA space.
Let's start with Google search.
This is now backed about by
service
worker, makes loading  faster
and more reliably.
It drops download time by 50
percent
and they are not -- at the scale
of storage as a huge user
experience.
The service worker enables a
whole category of new speakers.
When you are search and you're
offline you get a error message.
With service worker, they will
notify
you when you are back online and
your information is ready.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: Here is
bulletin.  They have a PWA and
another example of the use on
the web.
They are all about capturing
time
sensitive news events as they
unfold so you can get to the
site of the action without
friction.
The bulletin team has a super
development story because they
can get
to Android, iOS and more without
a
single progressive use base.
>> MALTE UBL: Another study
has a
low cost device for gaining
access to fast growing markets
like India.
Map skills, service worker is
added to the web screen.
It is for low network, it is
good for less reliable networks
and uses less
money when your Internet is
metered.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: This
represents 15 percent of all
time spent on Chrome and Android
and 20 percent on Chrome for
desktop and over 30,000 years of
video are watched daily in
Chrome worldwide.
I think this actually may be my
kids alone.  Maybe.
So a bunch of media specific
work has been happening on the
platform.
First the platforms gained a
bunch of new media features,
like the new API with lock
screen controls on the screer
and Vimeo is an example of a
user who
integrated this and has seen
strong usage.
There is the media capabilities
API,
you can make inr ninth choices.
Pictures and picture support.
This is across desktop and
mobile devices and new
presentation API that allows you
to explicitly control what you
show on secondary displays and
let's talk about offline support
for a minute.
It is a major use case for many
parts
of the world that limits access
to high width bandwidth.
So globo and boots are enabling
the
new web line APIs into their Web
sites
and there's next generation open
royalty free code ECC coming.
We developed partnership with 30
media
companies and 30 percent -- this
will have a big impact, shipping
in Chrome later this year.
Okay.  So we have been
focused on mobile but now I want
to talk about desktop for a
minute.  It is an audience that
remains in the
billions and productivity web
apps like G suite kin continue
to grow.  And like Starbucks,
mobile focused experiences are
finding big traction when they
come over to desktop.
We are starting to take mobile
lessons over to the desktop and
one of the things we are doing
is adding support
for add to home screen to
Chrome.
Once you install PWA to the
desktop it
gets its own icon and top level
window.
Findly you can use alt tab or
cmd-tab to get to Windows and
because it is powered by the
full Chrome browser you
get access to Chrome's browser
afford answers like auto fill.
These features are available in
beta in ChromeOS today and they
will ship to everyone in June
and we'll follow with Windows
and Mac later this year.
Also a big Spotify fan.  I'm
excited about the next spim.
They are shipping for PWA
features and you can experience
it now on ChromeOS.  It's a
great fit.  The web gives music
fans a fast and convenient way
to get right into Spotify and
listen to favorite songs and
desktop
PWA is a itch client that allows
for
play back of music and it has
Spotify
for remotely playing music or
through
speakers or other features and
Spotify apps that are running.
You can get into it with no
installation hurdles or updates
to manage.
>> MALTE UBL: Well, that is
cool but let's talk about
something even more exciting.
Email.
I imagine half my life in Gmail
and super awesome update we
original.
It is the original web app and
now a
desk PWA with these knew
features will be a true top
level window.  You can treat it
like any other app running on
the operating system.  The
boundaries between websites and
apps are blurring on desktop as
well.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: There is
another example I want to share.
Auto-CAD.
So auto-CAD popularized computer
aided design since initial
release in 19 Yao and continues
to innovate today.  There is
estimated two to 5 million
auto-CAD drawings files opened
every day
and billions of them are stored
in hosted file services.  This
is a great fit for these types
of files.
They set out to create a
web-based
editor years ago but found their
complex optimized code base was
impractical to write in
Javascript.  So enter web
assembly.
It is a new standard that allows
execution of code right in the
browser and gives this code
access to web APIs.  This opens
up a bunch of interesting
new use cases for the web like
enabling
large C++ code bases,
performance
sensitive code run in the
browser such as immediate code
and enables games on the web.
Unreal and unity, really popular
gaming engines can target web
assembly
and using web GL ugh do high
performance 3D gaming.
Best part, web assembly is
available
today across the major modern
brossers in mobile and desktop.
First time in the history of the
web that we had abroadly
available
alternative to Javascript across
browser.
>> MALTE UBL: Another big
moment, actually.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: Let's get
back to
auto-CAD, they launched a new
app in Mayur that was able to
take the
35-year-old code base, older
than the
web itself.
>> MALTE UBL: Older than me
almost.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: And they
are able to bring it to the web
and auto-CAD is universally
accessible on all devices
instantly.  If you are away from
your workstation you can make
edits to CAD drawings regardless
of operating system and the
engineering team has a shared
C++ code base.  As they make
changes they are easily
integrated into the web  app.
So web assembly in Chrome is
powered
by V8, the Javascript engine.
Good time to talk about
performance.
We are optimizing for real world
website and in partnership with
the community we created a new
benchmark called speed meter 2.
This measures Java performance
in a web app  reimplemented in a
dozen web frameworks and we are
pleased to share that over the
past year our performance
on the score has dramatically
improved including 112 percent
improvement with react with
significant performance gains
across other frameworks, as you
can see.
>> MALTE UBL: Your react apps
will
run twice as fast to compared to
a year ago on the same
hardware.
That's amazing.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: In
addition to
this VM has a bunch of new
Javascript features.  Be sure to
check out the talk for in
details.
>> MALTE UBL: It's really
excited with the next topic.
Who has put it and found out it
doesn't work the same way with
other browser.  Like 50 years
ago we developed for IE and it
didn't work in Firefox.
The browsing exainlts have not
changed.  There is light at the
end of the channel.
In your own project do you have
unitest?  Do you feel bad about
it?  The web never had anything
about that.  Web standards are
finally a thing.  Automated
tests are shared amongst
browsers to develop
implementations to make sure
that when service organize
comes out you have new
capabilities.
Browsers are becoming compatible
and
we want to thank the countless
volunteers helping with
compatibility.
As you can see in the chart,
only one browser is going down
over time but all  features of
the engine are going up.  There
is a lot of work to do.  We are
excited that things are going on
the right track.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: Going to
shift gears now and move on from
the Web Platform to the tools,
libraries and frameworks that we
are working on here at Google to
make web development more
productive.  Let's get started
with the tool that we ship to
every Chrome user worldwide.
Chrome's own dev tools.
Millions of developers use this
every single day and it keeps
getting better and better.
Please welcome Paul Irish, here
to give us a taste of what is
now this year.
(Applause.
) >>>
PAUL IRISH:  Thank you, Ben.
All right.
So it's 2018, right?  The world
is  asynchronous.  When we are
debugging, we can't necessarily
step through code line-by-line.
We have timers and promises and
network activities to contend
with.
So the Chrome dev tools have
transformed to adapt to this new
asynchronous world as well.  Let
me show what it was like a year
ago.
We have this little function,
time out with console log within
it.  And we'll just take a look
at what happened.  So this is
Chrome from a year ago.  I want
to step into the console, into
the set time out to pause in the
console log.  When I hit step
into, we step past it.  It is
not really what you want.
In today's Chrome, we have the
same code.  We step in and jump
into the invocation in the set
time out.  Now we are paused
right on that log method point.
So this is what we expect
when we hit set time out, right?
Set time out, like stepping,
debugging, this should match our
expectations of being in the
asynchronous world.  I showed
this with time out but you can
expect the same kind of
debugging upgrades when you work
with Web Platform
features like post message, web
workers, and more.
So speaking of features, Web
Platform evolves quickly, right?
Now, a as it evolves we as
developers have to feel
comfortable with the new APIs,
new objects and how our code
interacts.
The console has been our home
base for that  exploration.
So I'm excited to share with you
a
brand new dev tools feature that
I think  revolutionizes how we
interact with the console.  We
call it Eager Eval.
The best way to explain it is
with a demo.  Let's do that.
Switch over to my machine here.
Okay.  So we have this little
code right here, a regular
expression we are going to call
exec on it.  We have a string.
Let me finish off this string.
All right.  Now, as I finish
off everything, watch this.
Now, I didn't hit enter yet, but
I'm already getting the results
of this evaluation.  The cool
thing is, we are going to update
this as we type.  So let me go
over here.
Will this even work if I change
this to using parens around --
no.  All right.  So the regular
expression is a little brittle.
I'll admit it, okay.
But I do see, okay the zero to 9
range.  We could actually
improve this.  Actually, all
three of them.
Let's select all three and
replace it with slash D and
yeah, okay, looks like we are
still pulling out the same
stuff.  So that's good.
The other thing I wanted to
do, I wanted to pull the area
code out of this phone number
right here.
While we have the multiple
cursors, let's go ahead and add
capture groups to the regular
expression.  All right!  Boom,
boom, boom.  Capture, capture,
capture.  Area code is 1.  All
right.  Sweet.
In a few short moments we
explored and API, found a bug,
made improvement and got the
result we were looking for.
Pretty awesome.
Let's switch back to the
slides.
So really, that demo was just a
taste.
Eager Eval enables you to work
with
all sorts of Javascript
language, and the power thing
about it is that you can gernt
there will be no side  effects.
The way that we enable this is
we
introduce a new mode in V8 where
we attempt to evaluate
Javascripts.
If its about to cause aside
effect we just bail.
Speaking of V8 we have been
working heart to bring the same
dev tools experience from the
back end -- sorry, from the
front end to the back end by
making it a good tool for
NodeJS.
You can use the same tool set on
the server that you normally do
on the client.
We have covered a lot of
ground on this.  If you would
like to see more, check
out the dev tools talk where we
will be diving deeper into this.
Thank you guys very much.
(Applause.)
>> BEN GALBRAITH: Thanks, Paul.
So if you didn't notice on the
slide, Paul's session starts
bright and early tomorrow, but
it's worth the effort to get an
early start.  I encourage you to
attend.
Okay.  I want to talk about
another feature called
Lighthouse.  This gives you
clear guidance on how the
website can be improved and
categories such as performance,
accessibility, capabilities and
more.
People are actually using
this.
So far this year over 500,000
developers have used it to
analyze over 2 million pages.
So we are working hard to make
Lighthouse better.  This year we
are launching a new version 3.
0 with refined UI and higher
quality insights and announcing
new Lighthouse API to bring
insights into the workflow and
enable integration with other
tools and platforms.
Lighthouse generates insights
but in the real world there are
variables that influence how
your site performs like variable
network conditions or the
different devices that people
are using.  So late last year we
launched the Chrome user
experience report to help with
this.  It contains real world
performance data showing how
Chrome users are experiencing
over 4 million global  domains.
You can analyze the data set
yourself using the free big
query tool.  We also integrated
it into the page
feed insights tool, the easiest
way to see this data.  You can
compare yourself to your
competitors which can be very
motivating.
Okay.  So we also introduced
the Puppeteer open source
project last year.  This is a
NodeJS library for controlling
the headless Chrome.
It gives you access to rendering
engine and dev tools.
This project is on fire with 3
million
installs and used by 600MPM
projects.  You never know about
these things.
Most important of all it has
30,000 GitHub  stars.
>> MALTE UBL: That is the most
important.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: It may be.
It went 1.0 in January and opens
up a bunch of
interesting use cases to
integrate Chrome into your
workflow.
We are releasing a new
Workbox library.  This makes
common worker service scenarios
significantly easier.  With it
you can transform code like
this, about creating cache files
into this.
>> MALTE UBL: I think Workbox
is the most under utilized
library in user.  I recommend
that you start with workloads.
It is incredibly easy instead of
rolling your own.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: Okay.
If done poorly, sign up and sign
in can be a big friction point
for users.
One-tap sign up and auto sign in
library currently in early
access can drive really big
impact.
>> MALTE UBL: What is the name?
>> BEN GALBRAITH: Name is is
one of the hardest problems in
computer science.  That is the
name.
This library controls a one-tap
sign in experience.  No typing,
no identity provider to remember
and no password to create.  When
users return to your site they
can sign back in really easily.
It works by drafting off of the
existing sign in that the user
has to the device with the
Google property like Gmail.  It
is based on the credential
manager web standard.
There are a few examples I want
to share here, where the
benefits come in.  First ret
PHIN a real estate company here
in the U.S. saw 80 percent
increase in sign ups after
implementing the one-tap library
and Trevago, one of the leading
hotel
companies, saw 200 percent
increase in reservations after
using this.  Payments is another
way where ops can go a long way
and we recently made Google Pay
available on the web.
>> MALTE UBL: That's a good
name.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: Took us
awhile to get there.
You can accept users from
payments payments from users who
have saved their information on
the Google account.
It is available to anywhere
people.
Platforms like smopify allow you
to buy with a single click.
This lets -- web components.
You can now use primitives that
are baked into the Web Platform
itself.  It has only been in the
past few
months that web components have
major support and there are
polyfills to reach all of them.
They give you a nice reusable
chunk of code that you can pass
around and create them with just
about every major framework.  We
created a website called custom
elements everywhere with up to
date compatibility information
on.
In preact, view and many others
are
entirely -- and angular elements
released angular elements to use
exen components within an
angular app.
Speaking of web components we
created
polymer to help your team
achieve reuse or custom didn'ts
or other develops.  This week
the team is releasing the next
major version, 3.
0 which adds  MPM and model
you'lls so
it works seam llsly.
It is unveiling a few cutting
edge
products here at I/O that have
fast loading web apps.  One is
lit HTML.
A 3D -- this has the latest
females
that enables a web app to froal
which gives a snappy fients
face.
Using the library you can create
library components that work
alongside some of your elements.
It is leveraging the Web
Platform to make the apps more
efficient and developing easier.
>> MALTE UBL: You just went
through a lot of stuff which
actually brings me
to the next topic, talking to
developers, one message comes up
over and over again.
Hey, Chrome team you push all
these
new features at I/O, but frankly
it is a bit overwhelming and we
are lost on what to do.
Obviously there may not be many
of you here.
This is great for experts who
like to dive deep on  topics,
but not everybody
is like that and not every
company can afford to be up to
date with the best practices.
You start out with a expert
team,
people with less context, it's
important
for your web app to remain
stable as you age.  You must
bring these folks along as well
and allow them to create great
experiences.
That's where the project I work
on, AMP, comes in.  This is a
web component library for
building reliably fast websites.
Using brass and ought 98ed
guidance to
success, map deploys great user
experience and incredible skill
scale.
There are 6 billion AMP pages
and they continue to load well
under one second measure from
Google search under the median.
This translates into business
success.
30 percent increase on their
AMP.
Shop clues, 20 percent, Chinese
new
site saw 2X increase in time on
site and 40 percent decrease in
bounce rate.
Talk about AMP and eCommerce,
Ali Express went all in on AMP.
They went for many of their
pages and back end to turn it
into a progressive web app and
they have seen great  results.
AMP is sometimes seen as
specific to Google search.  This
is a metric that filters out
graphic from Google search and
saw 31 percent increase in
search rate.
They have been using it succeed
30 in ads as well.
If you are making AMP ages, take
them to your AdWords account.
As we mentioned earlier, we are
focusing on great experiences on
the web.  AMP stories is such a
project because constant
consumption on mobile is
changing.
Life size full screen projects
are becoming more popular every
day.  This development happens
exclusively in native apps.  The
web is literally the best
platform to build these.  It has
all the capabilities needed to
create content but the technical
investment that each single
publisher would have to make to
implement them is  prohibitive.
They are drawn to walled gardens
that make things easy
end-to-end.
With AMP stories, they capture
story telling they are able to
publish on their website with
minimal technical  investments.
Instead of components with web,
they
have support with vertical
video, and interaction.  They
are designed for mobile but work
great on desktop.
AMP stories is a radical shift.
We are progressively enhancing
the plain old web page.  We are
working on best in class
features using web components
that can be added to a document
with minimal froiment.
This is' merse sieve light boxes
and VAOs that stay on the screen
as you scroll.
The goal, to summarize and get
to add as many web pages as
possible,
continuing to meet user
expectations.
This can be summarizing as a lot
of exciting thing but I wanted
to touch on a different example.
AMP is for everyone.  It comes
with limitations which is not
the right, being opinion eight
the means
some people have different
opinion.  Some people say I
don't want to use AMP.  That is
what the web is all about and we
are committed to making it
happen.
Look at the core features that
AMP brought.
Instant loading, seamless
integration.  The first two
explain themselves.
We talk about the next one,
seamless navigation later.
Google search provides the same
innovative experience for AMP
today for all users to implement
a new set of standards.
If you don't want to use it,
super  cool.  Let's take a look
at some of the
factors that show the AMP
experience.
As I mentioned, AMP pages load
in well
under one second with the Chrome
users
saying there is fast web page
load.
Pages meet or exceed the
standards.
Web page loads super quickly but
is not interactive because
Javascript blocks the thread.
Not a good user experience.  We
have metrics that give you a
holistic experience like the
user has when they visit a page.
Another feature is privacy
preserving loading.  With he
want to explain.  To achieve
instant loading download the
resource before the user clicks.
Otherwise it will be in the way
and things won't be instant,
especially in mobile.
With, we built methods for this.
In pre-fetching it is not what
the
user expects in terms of
privacy.
There is a cookie that sends you
an ad based on that although you
never ended up going to the
page.  AMP does not have this
problem.
We want to bring the privacy
friendly features to the wider
web.
That's where the web packaging
comes in.  It allows you to
bundle up the web
content and allow other parties
to keep the ... https.  Faster
Javascript loading can form the
missing primitive behind a more
decentralized web.
It allows for instant loading
for all content in the web for
packages.
It has one AMP specific, there
are all these things that we
don't like.  We couldn't be more
excited.
Okay, I talk about how this
standard is brand new but we
actually implement it in Chrome.
You can try it behind the flag
today.
My team is open source tool, the
Google team built a tool that
works with the packages.
And other companies make web
packages for the content.
To give this an impression of
how this all works together.
Please welcome Ludo from
Pinterest.
>> LUDO ANTONOV: Thank you.
Our focus is to help people
around the world discover and do
the things they love.  We wanted
to create a seamless experience
on the mobile web that puts
the right content in front of
our users enabling them to take
advantage of
discovering content and browsing
without slow load times or have
it flow direct to the app.  This
is why we are excited to show
how
we are using AMP, PWA and
packaging today in the product.
Start with a simple search
and switch to the demo.
So I have a five-year-old at
home.  She loves to make things.
And so I'm looking for some
spring craft ideas for her.
So here you will see that when I
click on the AMP page it loads
really fast.
Even though we are on an AMP
page you notice that the URL
says Pinterest.com.  This is
made possible by the web
packaging technology that
enables us to publish content
that can be served directly from
the Google cache.  It is a big
win for the privacy of our
users as all of their actions
are now contained within the
Pinterest.com origin.
From here you will see that when
I
click on this I was seamlessly
teen the app.  I can take
further action like save this to
my work ... oops.
But more importantly also once
I'm on
our PWA app, then I can add
Pinterest to the home screen and
from there show all
the cool ideas that I have
collected for my daughter so
that we can do them together.
So at Pinterest we are committed
to making world class experience
for our yours users.
We were the first platform to
scale and working with AMP and
we have been able to shave 70
percent of load times
per our users over billions of
pages and millions of users.
This is in a nutshell how our
mobile web experience is
evolving to help
people around the world find
insure
sphraition
to find inspiration.
(Applause.).
>> MALTE UBL: We allow package
loading of web fault.
As a I said earlier, the
standard is fill being finalized
and not ready to ship.
We expect significant changes
due to input from other
browsers and users.  We are
building the infrastructure for
you to make packages.  Stay
tuned for other announcements
this year.
Summarizing, across the
global we are seeing amazing
success as a result of the PWAs
in their websites.
If you have a AMP page check out
the
new components super easily
enhance the user  experience.
If you love to benefit from
Google's
expertise to create web apps,
through
willing toes like, bring AMP's
reliable user experience to the
wider web.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: It is
great to see what is happening
with AMP.  Throughout this talk
we have highlighted examples
where the web connects users
right to content.  Without any
installation steps.
We see this low friction model
of web
links as being akin to the super
power of the platform.
As Malte mentioned web packaging
is an exciting emerging standard
for a bunch of reasons.
I'm glad that AMP is able to use
it to solve your issues but
there is a bigger opportunity
here.
For web packaging to help lean
into the super power and go from
fast load types to no load times
whatsoever and do it for the
entire platform, not just AMP.
So what would this kind of
truly instant friction free
experience look like?  We would
like to show you a prototype.
Mall malt here is a demo that
the Google imagine team is
exploring.  You are looking
through storage and you click
one of the results, right?
You go to enlarge the image,
makes sense.  How do you go to
the web page where the image
came from.  Today you have to
click a little button.  You
might do that but also might not
do that.  What if instead you
could scroll to the page
instead?
We think that with this
experience there will be
significant higher number of
people actually move to the next
wage page which will be amazing
for publishing content and user
experience as well.  This is one
example.
We are super excited to make the
web
the most seamless and
frictionless experience.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: We are
running out of time.
The web presents a compelling
fantastic business opportunity
for all of us.  Use our insight
tools like Lighthouse to
understand where your site is
falling short where you have
opportunity to get better and
upgrade your site using the
latest Web Platform features.
>> MALTE UBL: Use AMP to
create rich content and commerce
experience and get consistently
high quality results.
>> BEN GALBRAITH: Use other
library
areas like framework, polymer
and angular.  And join us this
November at the Chrome dev
summit in San Francisco where we
will gather as a community to
talk more about the path forward
for the web.  Sign up at this
URL for more information and we
hope to see you there.  Finally,
thank you for attending the talk
today.  We hope you enjoyed it.
Thank you.
(Applause.
)
(Standing by.)
>> ANNOUNCER: Thank you for
joining this session.
Brand ambassadors will help you
find your place to the next
session.
If you are registered for the
next session in this room, we
ask you to
clear the room and join the line
outside.
)
(Please stand by.
The Stage 2 session Lessons from
Spectre and Meltdown, and How
the Whole Web is
Getting Safer will begin at the
top of the hour.
)
(
The Stage 2 session Lessons from
Spectre and Meltdown, and How
the Whole Web is
Getting Safer will begin in
approximately 15 minutes.
Please continue to stand by.
)
(GOOGLE I/O 2018 session on
Stage 2, Lessons from Spectre
and Meltdown, and How the Whole
Web is Getting Safer, will begin
in approximately seven minutes.
)
>> ANNOUNCER: At this time
please find your seat.
Our session will begin soon.
(Music playing.
)
>> ANNOUNCER: Welcome.
Thank you for joining.
Our session will begin soon.
(Music playing.
)
(The session is about to
begin.  Standing by.)
>> CHRIS PALMER: Hi,
everybody.  Thanks for coming.
I know you have a good selection
of entertainment this afternoon.
So I'm glad so many of you chose
security.  Hopefully we'll have
some good fun.  A little bit of
fear, not too much.
So today I am going to talk
about lessons that we learned
from the Spectre and Meltdown
vulnerabilities.
I'm Chris Palmer from the Chrome
security team.  We will be
giving this talk in two parts.
I'll talk about Spectre and
Meltdown and how we defended
against it.
In the second half my colleague,
Emily Schechter from Chrome
security will talk about what
you developers can do to make
the most of all of defensive
work we have been doing, in
addition not just about Spectre
and Meltdown but other good
stuff on the web and for
extensions too.
So we will talk about what
Spectre is and why it hurts the
web; what we are doing to defend
against it in a way that doesn't
damage the Web Platform itself.
And we gt a little close to that
as some of you may know and I'll
talk about what that was about
and what we are going to do to
get back to good.
And then as I was saying, there
is general advances that Emily
is also going to talk about.
There's some good stuff there.
So you may have seen this
logo.
It is one of those logod
vulnerabilities.  Meltdown is a
variant of it that affects the
operating system kernel.  We are
not going to talk about that
because we are focused on the
web and what we have to do in
sort of non-kernel space to be
safe.
So our concern is the open
Web Platform.  I would encourage
all of you to check
out the Spectre attack.
com website which describes the
both  attacks, the
vulnerabilities and also
the Google project 0 blog where
Jan
Horne, one of the  discoverers
of this set of problems goes
into extreme technical depth
which you may enjoy.  I won't
get too heavy in this talk.
We'll talk about what you need
to know to get the impact of it.
These vulnerabilities became
public in January of this year.
As a whole team of people who
discovered it, people from Graz
University in Austria,
University of
Adelaide and Rambus and
independent researchers.
Everyone sort of had an angle on
these things.
These are hardware
vulnerabilities, not software
vulnerabilities.   Fixing it is
a different situation than the
usual software patch.
We had to do a lot of work in
Chrome to get through it.
It was moderately terrifying.
By moderately I mean extremely.
And by extremely terrifying, I
mean don't panic.
It is handled and you can do
stuff and we did stuff and it is
going to be okay.  We'll get
through it.
But, you know, it was a little
scary.  I lost some sleep.
On the Chrome side, a lot of
people did a lot of work to make
this defense happen.
I'm sort of the messenger today,
but the V8 team, the will
Project Zero team and there's a
whole team called the site
isolation team and you'll be
hearing about them.  They did a
lot of work to get us through
this little adventure.  I'm sort
of presenting on their behalf.
I was just sort of the guy.
They did all the real work.
So the main impact of Spectre
and
Meltdown is the hardware has a
bit of a problem where if two
programs are running on the same
chip, they now have a -- they
can lose confidentiality
guarantee from each other.  One
can read the  secrets of the
other.  So that is a bad
problem.  The hardware is
supposed to protect against
that.
The way it happens is most
modern hardware has a feature
called speculative execution
where when you are about to
branch for an if statement, for
example, even before you know if
the if condition is going to
turn out to be true the computer
starts executing the if block
because if it does turn out to
be true, I the time you figure
that out some of the work is
already done.
It's a form of small scale
parallelism and it really helps
performance a lot.  It's a huge
advance.
So what happens if the
instructions,
if the if branch is not taken?
Then what?  Does that work?  You
don't see it.  It doesn't happen
in your program.  What happens
is, the computer never retires
those instructions.
So the work gets thrown away
with no side effects on the
registers or memory or anything
like that.  Except there's one
little catch.
The cache memory in the chip to
speed
up memory accesses, side effects
of loading memory that had to be
done during speculation remain.
And an attacker can observe
those side effects on the shared
cache resource.
That can happen both within and
across privilege boundaries,
like across user
to kernel, across from one
process to
another, and on the web across
origins.
So that is a pretty bad problem
and here is a little snippet of
how this might happen.
This is what we are calling a
speculation gadget.  It is a
snippet of code that either
might appear in a program
naturally or
the attacker might create it,
cause it to be in the program
such as with
Javascript, and this example is
probably
the  simplest possible way to
explain one variant of the
attack.  There are several other
variants.  This example is taken
from the Spectre paper.  I
didn't make this up.  I
definitely suggest reading the
paper.  It is very fun.
So what happens in the attack.
The attacker controls X, this
index to array 1.
It is out of bounds, beyond the
boundaries of that array.  The
attacker can also flush or cause
to be loaded some stuff into
cache memory.  There is various
ways to achieve that.  Previous
research showed how.
There's an out of bounds secret
beyond the edge of array 1 that
we'll call K that the attacker
wants to learn.  That is
breaking the confidentiality
guarantee.
The attacker causes that to
get in cache.
So accessing it is fast as
opposed to accessing things out
of main memory which is fairly
slow relative to the CPU speed.
So what happens here is
obviously we are going to do a
bounds check because, of course,
you would.  That causes
speculative execution.  It might
be the case, for example,
that fetching array 1 size from
main memory is going to be slow.
It is not in cache, let's say.
The computer is going to start
doing that Y equals array 2 and
then that's when the attack
happens.  Because what happens
is, that causes that memory to
get loaded into cache memory.
Then accessing it later will be
fast.  And that gives the
attacker, who can
control and see array 2 the
ability to
determine if for a guess N, for
every possible value of X, call
it N, just keep guessing in a
four-loop.
Eventually the attacker will see
that accessing N is fast and
then they will
know -- or accessing N as an
index of array 1 is fast.  Then
they will know that's the same
value as the secret.
And this scales
subexponentially.  It is
actually practical to do.  You
don't have to guess all possible
values of K.
You get to guess byte by byte
and additively take time.
So the attacker can just run
this in
a fore loop and they learn stuff
out of
bounds, stuff they shouldn't be
able to do.
How do we defend?  There is this
bad side  effect.  So you might
think as a lot of people at
first did:  Why don't we just
turn off speculation?  That
would be great.  The problem
goes away.  Or what if we just
didn't have cache memory
anymore?  Well, that is
completely untenable from a
performance perspective.
We really need speculation and
we
really need a large shared cache
to have low cost high
performance.  It is not  really
negotiable.
So we have to use a smarter
approach than the sort of big
dumb hammer that you might
imagine at first.  How does this
impact the web?  It had a huge
impact on operating
systems and Hypervisers and
that's other people have worried
about that.  I'm worried about
the web.
So the problem sort of could
generalize, but I'm just going
to focus
on the same origin policy, which
is what
we are hoping to achieve as our
main security principle in the
web.  Here is a picture of a
typical renderer project.
Chrome is a multiprocess
architecture and it is running
various processes to
run your various tabs and in any
one renderer process there might
be several different origins
happening at the same time.
In this case, we've got innocent
origins A, B, and C.  But
there's also a hostile origin
running in the same address
space.
And that origin can either
discover
or cause to be created
speculation gadgets like in the
previous slide.  Then it can
start reading data that
belong to origins A, B, and C
inside the same process.
So that is a loss of
confidentiality across origins
which is extremely bad for the
web.
Like I said, I lost some sleep,
but don't worry, we are going to
take care of it.
So the new baseline that we
now
operate in is just, we assume
that any code running in a given
address space in a given process
can read the whole address
space.  That's a significant
change from the previous status
quo.
So to do the attack, though,
it is not  automatic.  The
attacker needs a couple things.
They need a CPU that does do
speculation, which turns out to
be not all CPUs.
Certain low end ARM processors
don't.  So those are actually
safe.  But pretty much every
other machine does.
Every Intel desktop you've got,
every iPhone, high end Android.
So the attacker gets that.
You need a CPU with a shared
cache.  Again every machine has
that.  The attacker has that.
You need a high resolution clock
to the attacker can time the
difference
between accessing stuff out of
cache versus accessing stuff out
of main memory.  The better
resolution of that clock the
easier to achieve the attack.
Even fairly low resolution
clocks could still work, at
least in theory.
So a clock and there's tons of
clocks in the Web Platform.
Then the presence of such
gadgets, speculation gadgets or
the ability to create them which
obviously Javascript lets you
write whatever you want.
So all the preconditions are
met on the web.
So to defend, the first thing we
want to do is break those
preconditions.
So the one that came to mind,
everybody at first was like:
Let's get rid of high precision
clocks.
That's turns out to be not
really fees ib, unfortunately.
The Web Platform has a whole
bunch of
clocks, APIs that are clocks on
purpose, like performance.now
and there are APIs that turn out
to
be clocks by accident or
implicit clocks such as Shared
Array Buffer.
Everyone know what Shared Array
Buffer is?  Some, a few?  It is
a thing.  It is a way to let you
share data between a worker and
mor main thread, for example.
Than  turns out to be a
nanosecond
scale clock because the worker
can just increment a counter in
the Shared Array Buffer and the
main thread can say oh, hey,
what is our value now?  That is
about how many milliseconds,
sorry, nanoseconds have passed.
So it's a clock.
In order to make exploitation
not be
too easy we actually turned off
Shared Array Buffer.  Even
shortly after shipping it, which
is a real bummer for us.  We did
not want to do that.  People
need it to make cool
applications on the web.  And we
want the web to be cool and
powerful and to enable
interesting applications.
So we had a big old argument
about whether or not we were
really going to do that.  But we
did.  We are bringing it back
and I'll explain how.  But
unfortunately, I think that did
gain us something.  I think the
easiest route to
exploitation was  avoided in
that, by doing that.  And other
browsers did similar things.
And we all collaborated to sort
of figure out how we are going
to do this in a way that doesn't
hurt the web so we are all on
the same page.
I should mention that.  That's
kind of a happy story that comes
out of this.  A really good
collaboration between the
security teams of a lot of
different browser vendors.  It
has been a great experience for
all of us.  I think we are going
to come out with a much better
web thanks to the help of
everyone.  And we are going to
bring Shared Array Buffer back
once we made the web safe for
clocks, which sounds like a
funny thing to say.
So as I was sort of getting
at we
don't want to lightly toy with
the Web Platform.  It has to be
stable so that you can build
stuff on it.  If we are taking
APIs away or changing how they
behave, it is not a good
developer experience.  And that
therefore is not a good user
experience, obviously.  So we
can't do that too much.  And we
did not do it lightly.
And going forward, our goal is
to be
very, very careful and ship --
even more careful than before --
and ship things that we believe
that we won't ever have to
unship.
That is a tall  order, but super
bad
emergencies like Spectre have
sort of recalibrated our
thinking as to what kinds of
things are possible.
And that's kind of been fun, a
good adventure.  Frightening
form of fun that I kind of
enjoy.
Other things we can do.
Think back about that gadget.
What if we could turn off
speculation, not across the
board because that is not
tenable for performance reasons.
But what if we could just like
for this if check, when checking
array bounds, definitely make
sure you fully
checked it before you then
speculate further.  You can do
that actually.  Different CPU
architectures have different
instructions to let you say
don't go past this point until
you loaded this thing from
memory and so on.  You can sort
of turn off speculation on a
microscale.
And the V8 team here I cannily
worked
to do as much of that as they
can to get rid of speculation
gadgets in the
Runtime and change how they
compile code to not generate any
gadgets.  That is a very
difficult thing.  They had to do
a lot of work.
And unfortunately, it doesn't
get us all the way across the
finish line, but it definitely
again, like turning off Shared
Array Buffer it got us a little
breathing room to get through to
this point to now where we can
do more long-term things.
There's the low-level
defenses, but the web needs more
than just that.  We have to real
I do something about the origin
boundary per se.  We have to
uphold that thing directly.
That's what we are trying to do.
So think about a malicious site
that
can take over a renderer such as
by memory corruption or a logic
bug.
Something that we call universal
cross site scripting and that is
a bad bug.  They can cause other
origins that they want to attack
to be loaded in the renderer.
So we knew all along that we
needed a good way to defend
against that.
So years ago we started cooking
one up.
We call it Site Isolation.  It
turns out that Site Isolation is
super useful for Spectre also,
pretty much for the same reason.
What it does, it is a
rethinking of
how we apportioned origins to
processes.
In the past it is based on
resource
consumption and how busy is this
renderer, do we need a new one,
can we reuse one that has a
light load?
Now we are going to instead
line-up
sites with their processes,
their dedicated to them.
That gets hostile overage ins
out of
our address space of innocent
origins.
Here is a picture of the status
quo, a sort of block diagram of
the technology stack.  You have
your hardware, you have
kernel mode or ring 0 you have
user mode or ring 3.  You have
your kernel.  There's other user
land processes.  There is the
browser which is spawning
a renderer or maybe ten to run
origins A, B, C, D, whatever
else you have going.  So that is
the status quo.
We are changing that in a way
that seems simple when you draw
a picture, but it is an
incredible amount of work.
We had to fundamentally rethink
basic assumptions about Chrome's
architecture in order to achieve
this.
Navigation, it -- Javascript
APIs, it crosses the board.  It
is quite interesting.
Now site A, B, C, and D will
get their own renderer processes
and they will be isolated from
each other.
If D turns evil it can, via
Spectre,
it can read whatever it wants
out of its
own process an A, B, and C are
safe elsewhere.
Here is another picture, a call
back.  You can see now that the
hostile site is in its own
address space safely isolated
from the good friends A, B, and
C.
So this is a great solution.  We
think it is the way forward for
a variety of reasons, not just
Spectre.
Like I was saying it is also a
good defense against universal
process scripting.  There are
limitations.  One for thing I
have been saying site, not
origin.
A site is something we define as
being
the effective top level domain
+1 label below that.
So like NHS.gov.U.K.
That is the effective top level
domain, NHS1 level below, sim
allocated
com, one level below, Bing or
whatever.
So the whole host name includes
the port number.  For both of
these, scheme matters too.
You can't be the same site if
you are
HTTP as the same https verse of
your site.
The effective tld +1 or eTLD.
As you can imagine we will be
loading or launching more
processes, so that uses more
memory.
Unfortunately, a little more Ram
is going to be required.
Last, there's the thing called
cross origin read blocking,
which is a crucial part of Site
Isolation that requires you to
do a little bit of work.  It is
not a heavy lift.  Don't worry
too much.  Emily will explain
how you can get the most of it
and why it is important.
But it is a crucial thing
that you will all want to take a
look at.
The final thing that we are
changing
how we do for Spectre is before
we give super important
information to a
renderer like auto fill form
data, your
passwords, payment instruments,
we are going to gate that on
some cation that the user, the
person really wants to do it.
There boant won't be any sort of
automatic giving of super
sensitive information to
renderers.
So the person is going to be
maybe a little more in the loop
on some things than they have in
the past.
I really think that's important
especially given the fact that a
site being more broadly defined
than an
origin, a site may contain some
potentially hostile origins in
its same site instance,
therefore in the same process.
For example, super important
thing, that  example.
com and forgotten old Wordpress
installation dot example.com.
Those are currently in the same
site, obviously.  In the
long-term we would like to get
back to something closer to the
origin definition.
Anyway, we are going to make
sure that people want to do
things before we give
information to renderers.
There's things you can do
about this, including cross
origin re-blocking.  That's
where Emily comes in from
Chrome security team and she's
got some good information for
you.  Please give her a warm
welcome.
(Applause.
)
>> EMILY SCHECHTER: All
right.
So thanks so much, Chris, for
enlightening us about Spectre.
For overviewing ways that we are
making Chrome and the Web
Platform safer with Site
Isolation.
Now I know all of you may be
wondering what you can do about
all of this.  It turns out there
are actually lots of things that
you as web developers can do to
best amp up your defenses.
So I'll go over some steps
that you should take to keep
your web project secure.  First
I'll talk about steps that you
should take to get the most of
Spectre defenses.  Then I'll
talk about some general security
recommendations for website
developers and for extension
developers.
So first let's talk about the
Spectre-specific defenses.
There are two specific areas
that you'll want to think about
as a web developer.  Getting the
most out of cross origin read
blocking and cookie health.  So
I'll explain what both of these
are and about how you should
think about them.
First we'll talk about the
feature that Chris mentioned
called cross origin read
blocking and how you can get the
most of it.  So Chris just
talked about how Site Isolation
will put different sites into
different processes.  Even when
all cross origin pages are put
into separate processes, pages
can still legitimately request
some cross origin subresources
such as images and Javascript.
So to help prevent sensitive
information from leaking, Site
Isolation includes this cross
origin read blocking feature
that limits which network
responses are delivered to the
renderer process.
So why does this matter?
Well, imagine an attacker
creating an image tag that
includes a JSON file with
sensitive information like maybe
your bank balance.  Without Site
Isolation the contents of the
JSON file would make it to the
renderer process' memory, at
which point the renderer notices
that it is not a valid image
format and doesn't render the
image.  But now we have Spectre.
Now there is a way to
potentially read
that chunk of memory.
So cross origin read blocking
would actually prevent the
contents of this file from ever
entering the memories of
the process that the renderer is
running
because the mind pipe is
blocked by cross origin read
blocking.
So let's breakdown how this
works.
A website can request two types
of URLs from a server:  Data
resources and media resources.
So here data resources includes
text or code-like resources.
So had the MultiModal, XML, JSON
files.
A website is able to receive
data resources from its own
domain or other
domains with permissive CORS
headers.  Cross origin data
resources come from a different
site than the page that requests
them.  They do not have CORS
headers that would make them
accessible.
Media resources could include
things like Javascript or CSS.
Immediate media resources could
be included from any site.  The
cross origin read blocking
policy prevents a process from
receiving these data resources
from other origins if
they have an HTML XML or JSON
MIME type
and there is an X content type
options
nosniff response header and if
CORS
doesn't explicitly allow access
to the document.
Data resources blocked by this
policy are presented to the
process as empty, although the
request does still happen in the
background.
So here is an example for random
site.com where we have two cross
origin subresources from your
bank.com which might be some
pretty sensitive information.
The first looks like an image
but bit actually includes JSON
and it does not include a CORS
header.  So it will be blocked.
In the second request it is
fetching JSON but it does
include CORS.  If there is a
legal access control allow
origin header on the response,
it will be allowed.
So what this means is that to
benefit from cross origin read
blocking you need
to send the right contend type
headers so the cross origin read
blocking can recognize the
content as sensitive and block
it.
You should also tell the browser
not to MIME sniff.
We try to confirm that it is
correct
but you are better off doing the
the
right thing yourself that is
cross origin read blocking.
Let's move on to cookie health.
If we go back to the previous
example where the attacker
created an image tag that
included a JSON file with
sensitive
data, this actually only works
if your bank.com has stored a
cookie that automatically  logs
the user in.
And cookies typically get sent
for all requests to the website.
That sets the cookie even if the
request is made by a third-party
using the image tag.
Now we have same site
cookies.  They are a new
attribute that specify
that a cookie should only be
attached to a request that
originates from the same site.
Hence the name same site
cookies.
Right now Chrome and Firefox are
supporting this attribute.  If
you are not using Javascript,
there
are ways you can stop the
cookies data from the rendering
process.
You can set the cookies
attribute which prevents the
cookie from being
accessed on  supported site
scripts like Chrome.
If HTTP is possible, you can
limit
the exposure by not reading
document.cookie unless it's
absolutely necessary.
So that wraps up how you as a
web developer should make
changes to best mitigate
Spectre.  We have this
information posted online on our
web fundamentals article.
Definitely check back there for
more updates.
So now that we've talked
about ways to mitigate Spectre,
let's talk about other ways that
you can keep your web projects
safe.  I say projects here
because many of these methods
are applicable for both websites
and Chrome Extensions.
So there are three overall
categories to think about
improving security for your site
or  extension.  The first is
using web security standards.
So https is one of our favorite
topics on the Chrome security
team.  I would be remiss if I
didn't remind you that when
sending or requesting data you
should always avoid HTTP.  This
is important for website
developers an it is also
important for extension
developers too.
You should never be using plain
HTTP in your extension.
Https is just the bare minimum
that web users today expect in
terms of site security.
At 4:00 p.m. today, right
after this talk, but over
on stage 6, Adrian and Dan Mac
he will Wayne will talk about
trends we are seeing and the
latest and greatest updates in
UI changes in Chrome.  Go check
out that talk.
If you are not using https,
check out our setup guide to
figure out how to get started.
Content security policy
provides a rich set of
directives that enable
granular control over the
resources that a page is allowed
to load and where it is loaded
from.
This is an awesome way to help
prevent cross origin scripting
attacks and you
can use their policy violation
reporting tools that you may not
know about.
I recommend that you check out
the web fundamentals article to
learn more.
Extension developers, CSP is for
you too.
You should include an explicit
CSP for the extension in the
manifest.
So if you are using content
security
policy in your policy it might
look something like this.  If
the extension is only loading
resources from itself you can
register CSP.  If the extension
needs to include scripts from
specific codes they can be
included here as well.
So that is just a quick primer
about
what you should know in terms of
web security standards.
Now let's move on to protecting
developer accounts.
This one is actually
particularly important for
developers of Chrome Extensions.
If you are a developer of a
Chrome Extension you might not
realize it, but you actually now
have a lot of power because your
code is running on a lot of
users' browsers.
If your developer account is
proceed
miced, an attacker could push
malicious code directly to a the
look of users.
This seems like you've become a
juicy target for attackers.
What this means, you should
definitely take extra care to
protect your developer account.
Google released the advanced
protection program to safeguard
the Google accounts of those
most at risk of targeted
attacks.  It includes phishing
protection with a physical
security key.   Safeguarding
your emails and files by
limiting access to non-Google
services.  And blocking
fraudulent account access with
extra steps to verify that it's
you.
But if the advanced protection
program is not for you you
should definitely still take
other measures to protect your
accounts.  For example you
should enable two factor
authentication and preferably
with a security key.
Finally I'll talk about price
protection.  And here I'll --
privacy protection and here I'll
focus on permission.
First, permissions best
practices for
web developers and then I'll
talk about
permissions best practices for
extension  developers.
On the web when you use certain
powerful APIs like key location
or push
locations, Chrome will ask the
user for permission to use that
powerful ape.  It is important
for you as a developer for you
to ask your users how you will
be using that information.  If
users understand the value that
permission brings at the time
when you ask for it.
So, for example, here we have a
hypothetical airline web app.
You can see there's a check box
at the bottom of the screen for
user to indicate that they want
notifications for flight delays.
So after a user checks this box,
is a
great time to ask for the push
notification permission because
the value of getting
notifications for flight  delays
is really clear.
A much worse user experience
would be, for example, just
spamming the user
on page load all the time for a
bunch of permissions that might
seem random at that point.
So now I'll move to
permissions best practices for
extension developers.  We will
cover two best practices.
Reducing required permissions
and using optimal permissions.
So first reduce required
permissions.
The APIs and extension can
access is specified in the
permissions field of the
manifest and the more
permissions are granted the more
avenues and  attacker has to
intercept information.  Only the
APIs that an extension depends
on should be listed.
Extensions that are using
host
permissions to inject scripts
can often substitute asset tab
instetted.
The activeTab permission will
grant temporary access to the
current activeTab only when the
urine vox the
permission and access is cut off
when the user navigates away
from or closes the  tab.
This serves as a good use for
many URLs.
You should also empower users to
choose which features and
permissions they need from an
extension by including optional
permissions.  If a feature is
not essential to the core
functionality of an extension
make it optional and move the
API or domain into the optimal
permissions field.
Here is what using optional
permissions looks like in our
manifest.  Okay.  We just
covered a lot of best practices.
We covered how you can take
advantage of protections from
Spectre and we  covered other
best practices to keep your
website or your extension safe
using web security  standards,
developer account protection,
and permissions best practices.
At Chrome we believe in
creating a web that is easy to
use securely by default and we
continue to work on security
protections that make the entire
web safer.
So as developers, go out there,
take advantage of these tips and
resources so that together we
can continue to build a platform
and ecosystem that is safe by
default for everyone.  Let us
know if you have any feedback on
the talk.
We'll be in the web Sandbox area
after the talk if you have any
questions.
Thanks.
(Applause.
)
(Music playing.)
>> ANNOUNCER: Thank you for
joining this session.  Brand
ambassadors will assist with
directing you through the
designated exits.  We will be
making room for those who
registered for the next session.
If you reg spheared for the next
session in this room, please
clear the room and return via
the registration line outside.
Thank you.
)
(The session concluded.
(
The GOOGLE I/O 2018 session
What's New
in the Android Runtime (ART)
will begin in approximately 20
minutes on Stage 2.
)
(Please stand by.
The GOOGLE I/O 2018 session
What's New in the Android
Runtime (ART) will begin on
Stage 2 in approximately 20
minutes.
)
(The GOOGLE I/O 2018 Stage 2
session What's New in the
Android Runtime (ART)
will begin in approximately ten
minutes.  Please continue to
stand by.
)
(Music playing.)
(The next Stage 2 session will
begin
in approximately five minutes.
What's New in the Android
Runtime (ART).
)
>> ANNOUNCER: At this time
please find your seat.  Our
session will begin soon.
(Music playing.
)
>> MATHIEU CHARTIER: Hello,
everyone.
This is Matthew and this is my
colleague Calin and today we
will be
going over what is new on
Android Runtime, also known as
ART.  What is ART?  Well, ART is
the software layer in between
the plirks and the operating
system.
It provides a mechanism for
executing Java language and
call-in in  applications.
To accomplish this ART does
two things.
It executes Dex files, the
intermediate representation of
Android applications through a
hybrid model
consisting of the
interpretation, just
in time compilation and profile
base ahead of time compilation.
ART also does memory
management for
Android applications through an
automatic recollect  clammation
through a Garbage Collector.
This is a concurrent compacting
garb clang so there is less jank
in your applications.
Now, let's look at how ART
changed over the years.  Over
the years there have been many
improvements to art.
In Nougat we introduced profile
compilation to reduce memory
usage and reduce storage
requirements.
Also in Nougat we added a git
must like Dalvik used to have.
This was done to remove the need
for optimizing apps.  That was a
big problem during Android
system updates.
And in Oreo we added a new
concurrent compacting Garbage
Collector to have
less jank as well as accelerate
applications.  As you can see on
the slide this new
Garbage Collector enables a now
bum pointer allocator 17 times
faster than
the  allocator in Dalvik or
KitKat.
Now, we talked about what
happened in the past.  What's
new in Android P?  First of all,
there are new compiler
optimization s to help
accelerate the performance of
call-in code in Android.
This is especially important
since Kotlins the first class
programming language for Android
development.
Next up, we have memory and
storage optimizations to help
entry level
devices such as Android Go
devices.
This is important to help
improve the performance for the
next billion users.
Finally we have cloud
profiles.  Device  collected
profiles from the
just in time profiler are
uploaded and aggregated in the
cloud to enable faster
performance directly after
installation of applications.
Okay.
So let's start with Kotlin.
Last year we announced Kotlin as
the first class officially
supported programming language
for Android
development and we began to
investigate  performance.  Why
Kotlin?
It is a safe,  expressive,
concise object oriented language
that is
designed to be interoperability
with Java language.
The reason ART focuses on
optimizes Kotlin so the
developers can leverage
all language features by having
fast and jank-free applications.
Let's see how Kotlin oppedzs are
performed outside of Runtime.
Usually they are performed in an
investigative manner and there
is an order of preference for
fixing performance issues so
that the most
amount of Kotlin applications
can
actually benefit from the
applications.
The first preamps is call link.
Google and JetBrains work
closely
together on all implementations
on fixes issues.  If we fix a
performance here it will be able
to be deployed flow the most
Kotlin applications.
Alternatively if that doesn't
work we
consider   fixes the issue
inside of
byte code converts which enables
existing versions of the
platform to get the performance
fix F that option doesn't work,
the last operation is to fix the
performance issue in the Android
Runtime also known as ART.  So
the reason that we might not
want
to fix an ART right away, ART is
updated as part of the Android
platform.  That means that not
all devices will get the fix.
Now, let's look at an
example.
One example of a Kotlin
optimization is the parameter
null check.  As you can see
here, this is a simple method
that just returns the length of
a
string, but the string is
nullable.  So what this means is
that the compile
Erin certificates a null check
into the function byte code.  So
actually verifies that the
string is not null and throws
the corresponding exception if
required.  Implemented in the
bytecode the first step is
loading the name of the
parameter and then invoking a
separate function to do the
actual null check.
There is some extra overhead
here as you might see because
the invocation in
the common case you could the
extra invocation to do the
function to return the null
check.  If required, they call
the third
function to throw the parameter
as a null check.  These are
commonly required for Java
language and Kotlin
interoperability
because goof language does not
have null property.
How can we optimize this?
If we look at the byte code, we
can in line the method that does
the null check into the caller.
After inlining, this improves
performance.  There is one less
invocation and from here you can
see one other thing we can
do is that the name of the
parameter is not actually
required unless the will
argument is null.
So from here we can do code
syncing to move loading as a
parameter name inside the
conditional.
The overall these two
optimization s
help performance by removing one
cation
and one loadings a string
literal.
We also track cot lip
performance on various
benchmarks.
Other improvements include
improved opens loops.
Incontinue sick methods
taylorred for
Kotlin code to enhance
performance there.
The Kotlin team is always
working on this pop answer.
What about memory and storage
improvements?
So since ART is responsibility
for
Java language and Kotlin, it is
important that they don't use
too much mem or space on the
device.  There have been several
improvements on this area
including the amount of
space and memory usage by Dex
files.
Now why are Ram and storage
important
in optimization important in
recall last
year we introduced a new
initiative.
Android Go on entry level
devices.  Since these devices
typically have one
gigabyte or less of Ram and
eight gigabytes or less of
storage, it is kind
of important to focus on
optimizing these areas so the
users can run enough
applications and install as many
applications or more
applications than they would
otherwise be able to.
Now, this isn't just for
Android Go.  Premium devices
also benefit from optimization s
in these two areas.  Since they
have more resources
normally it is to a lesser
degree.
Anyway, before we talk about Ram
and storage optimizations, let's
do a little
bit of review on how
optimization applications work
on Android devices.  Application
comes in a package kit known as
an APK weds.
Inside of the APK weds there are
one
or more Dalvik executable files
that ART uses to compile or
interpret your application.
These Dex files are required
to be quickly accessed during
execution.  They are mapped
directly into memory during
application startup so that ART
can have quick access.  This
means that there is a startup
cost as well as the Ram cost
proportional to the size of the
Dex file.
Finally, Dex files are
usually stored twice on the
device.  The first place they
are stored is inside of the
application package kit.  The
second place they are stored is
in an extracted form that ART
can have faster access during
application start
up without needing to extract
from the zip file each time.
Let's take a closer look at the
content of Dex files.  Within a
Dex file there are several
sections containing different
types of data related to the
application.  But where is the
space going in the Dex file?
One way to do this is you can
calculate where the space is
going for each Dex file and
average out the results.
This chart here is for the top
99 most downloaded applications
in the Play Store.
You can see the largest is the
code he can instructions used by
ART.  The next largest section
is the string data section.
This section contains the string
literals downloaded, class names
and field names combined these
two sections are around 64
percent of the Dex files.  They
are pretty important areas to
optimize.
Let's see if there is a way we
can
reduce the size of these
sections.
One new feature introduced in
Android P is called CompactDex.
The golf CompactDex is simple:
Reduce the size of Dex files to
get memory and storage savings
on the device.  From the
previous slide we saw that some
sections are larger than others.
So it is important to just focus
on the largest sections to get
the most savings.
Run the code items, there are
more
often deduplicated and have the
headers shrunk inside of the
application.  And another thing
here worth noting about string
data is that large applications
frequently ship multiple Dex
files in their APK because of
Dex
format limitations smekly the
64K limit
means they can only have
64,000 methods in the Dex files
before needing another one in
the application.
Every time you add another Dex
files it causes duplication of
string data that otherwise could
be stored only once.
CompactDex streengs this by
providing deduplication across
the files in APK.
Now, let's go to the
generation process.
First let's look at how Dex
files are processed on Oreo.
The first step run by Dex code
the ahead of time compiler are
that the files are extracted
from APK and stored
in a D Dex filer so they can be
loaded more efficiently during
application start up.  One thing
worth noting is the profile.
The profile as introduced in
Nougat is essentially data about
the application execution
including which methods are
executed during startup, what
methods
are hot or compiled by the git
compiler and what is loaded.
On Oreo we are already
optimizing the
files stored in the D Dex
container by applying.  And
which methods to compile based
on what methods are hottest in
the Dex file.
Now, let's look at Dex
processing on Android P.
In Android P, the out of time
compiler
has a more CompactDex by
representation inside the
container.
One new introduce is the shared
data section, data present in
multiple Dex files will be in
the shared data files
only one it deduplicates data
common hi shared and one of the
most shared is the string data
which is how we reduce the
large string data section we saw
earlier.
Since this is done on the device
that means that all existing
applications get the benefits of
CompactDex without needing to
recompilation pile their APKs.
Okay.  So let's look at one
example of how we shrink the Dex
code items.  Apart from the
instructions each code item has
ab 16 bite header and then most
of the values in the header are
usually small values.
What we do here is we shrink the
field in the header to be four
bits each.  We have an optional
free header to
extend them as requiredment.
The pre-header is zero bytes in
most cases but can be 12 bytes
in the worst case.
So other than the pre-header, we
also shrink the instruction
count.  Since the affirm method
is not going
to be that large we shrink this
down to 11 bits instead of 32
bits and use the five remaining
bits for flags that are
specific.
Finally we move the debug
information into a separate
space efficient table to help
enable more deduplication of the
code items.
Overall this optimization saves
around
12 bytes per code item in the
CompactDex file.
And here are the results for the
top 99 most downloaded APKs.
The average space required by
the Dex times on the device is
11.6 percent smaller.  And other
than the stored savings you also
get memory savings because the
Dex files are resident in memory
during application usage.
At least partially resident
memory.
One more thing here.
Let's go over the late yowt
optimizations a bit.  Even
though we introduced the git
profiles in Android N we did not
have any layout optimizations
back then.  What that means, Dex
is randomly
ordered and not disregarding the
usage pattern.
In Android O we added this type
of optimization that groups the
methods used during application
startup toghtd and the methods
that are hot that means
the code is frequently accessed
during execution together.
This seems like a pretty big win
so far.  Let's see what we did
for Android P.
In Android P we have more
flexible profile information
which enables us to put the
methods used only during startup
together.  This helps reduce the
amount of memory used because
the application or operating
system can remove those pages
from memory after startup.  We
also put the hot code together
since it is frequently accessed
during execution.
Finally we put the code that was
never touched at all during
execution at the
end so it is not loaded in
memory unless required.
The reason that the layout are
important, they reduce locality
and.
If you improve the locality here
you
get startup benefiting here,
memory, and reduction of memory
usage.  Now to Calin for cloud
profiles.
(Applause.)
>> CALIN JURAVLE: Thank you,
Matthew.  Hello, everyone.  My
name is Calin and I'm here today
to present to you how we plan to
improve
and scale up the Android Runtime
profiling infrastructure.
However before we start
profiling, is an over  loaded
term.
When we speak about profiling in
today's presentation we will
talk about the metadata that is
going to be fit into a profile
guided optimization process.
We are going to see how we
extend the on device
capabilities in order to drive
performance right against all
time.
Before we gum into what is
new and how actually it works
let me briefly
remind you how Android juice
guided profile optimization.
This is a technique we
introduced in
Android Nougat as part of a
hybrid execution model.
That means that the code can be
in three different optimization
states at the same time.
The primary goal of this
technique is to improve all key
metrics of the application
performance.  We are talking
about faster application tart
tup time.  Reduced memory
footprint.  A better user
experience by providing less
jank during usage.
Less disk space used by the
compiler artifact which means
more disk space for our users
and nonetheless increased
battery life because we do have
optimization when the quia's not
used rather than during the use
time.
How does this work?
It all starts when the Play
Store installs the application.
But first we do very, very light
optimization and we have the
application ready to go for the
user.  But first launch the
application will start in what
we call an interpretation mode.
The Runtime executes the
application code, it discovers
the most frequently used method
and most important methods to be
optimized.
That's when a git system kicks
in that will optimize the code.
During this time, the JIT system
also records what we call the
profile information.
This profile information
essentially encapsulate data
about the methods that are being
executed and about the classes
that are being  loaded.
Every now and then we dump
this profile to disk so that we
can reuse it later.  Once the
device is put aside and is
not in use, a stage which we
call idle maintenance mode, we
are going to use
the profile to drive profile
guided optimization.
The result is an optimized app
that will eventually replace the
original state.
Now, when the user relaunches
the app
it will have a much messier
startup
time, better steady state
execution and overall the
battery will drain less.
In this state the application
will be
interpreted just in time
compiled or pre-optimized.
Now, just how efficient is this
technique?  We gathered some
data from the field for Google
maps applicants.  Here you can
see two charts.
The left one presents data from
a marshmallow build.
You can see the startup time is
pretty constant over time.  It
does not fluctuate.  This is
pretty much expected.  You don't
want to have a deviation here
practice.
However on the right-hand side
you can see that in Nougat the
startup time drops over time.
Eventually it stabilizes, being
about 25 percent faster than it
used to be in the install time.
This is great news.  It means
that the more the user uses the
app, the more we can optimize
it.  Over time the performance
gets better and better.
This is great.  But we can do
better and we want to do better.
There shouldn't be, we shouldn't
need to wait for optimal
performance.
And our goal with cloud profile
is to deliver near optimal
performance right after install
time without having to wait for
the application to be profiled.
So let's see how this is
going to work.  Let me introduce
you to the idea of cloud
profile.
This is based on making two key
observations.
First one, is that usually apps
have
many commonly used code paths
shared
between a multitude of users and
devices.
Take, for example,
(indiscernible) startup time.
Each device will have its own
specific steps.  However,
globally we can extract the
common intersection of all those
classes and there is available
data for us to optimize upon.
Second we noticed most app
developers
put all of their apps
incrementally
starting with alpha beta
channels, one, 2 percent of
their database.
The idea behind cloud profile
is to
use this initial set of A beta
users to bootstrap performance
for the rest of the users.
How is it going to work?
Once we have an initial set of
devices, we are going to extract
the profile information about
your APK from those devices.  We
are going to upload that
information to play.  And there
we are going to combine
everything.  We are going to
aggregate whatever comes in and
we are going to generate
what we call oi CORS headers
application profile.
This CORS headers profile will
contain information which is
relevant across all device
executions and not just a single
one.
When a new device requests
for the application to be
installed, we are going to
deliver this CORS headers
profile alongside the main
application APK to the device.
Locally, the device will be able
to
use that data to perform profile
guided optimizations right at
install time.
That will deliver and improved
startup performance and much
better steady state performance
over time.
Now, having profiles in the
cloud
offers much more opportunities
than
directly inferencing the
performance with profile guided
optimization.
The CORS headers profile offers
data, for example for developers
to act upon.  We believe there
is enough information there so
that developers can tune their
own application.  We are going
to explore how we can share this
data later.
Now, we can see in this workflow
that to deliver such a thing, we
need to
Android from Android platform
and play alike.
Today's presentation we are
going to focus on the Android
platform.
-- Android P support.  What
did we do in P to support this
lifecycle?  We added new
interfaces that will
allow us to extract the profile
and bootstrap the information
from the cloud.
The functionality is
available to all
system level apps which acquired
the necessary  permissions.
And in our case play is just a
consumerrer.
The two APIs I'm talking about
are profile extraction and these
are exposed
via a new platform manager
called ART manager.
The second API is profile
installation.
And this is seemingly integrated
in the current  installer
session.  What we did here is to
add a new kind
of installation artifact that
the platform understands.
We called this Dex metadata
file.  Essentially in a similar
way to the
APK, the Dex metadata files are
archived, which will contain
information
in how the Runtime can optimize
the application.
Initially this Dex metadata
files will contain the CORS
headers profile that I mentioned
about earlier.
But install time play will
deliver these files if they are
available to the device, where
they will be streamlined into
the Dex optimizer on the device.
It is worthwhile mentioning
that we will offer support for
Google Play dynamic delivery.
So if you plan to split the
functionality of your
application a bit in different
APKs, all the APKs will have
their own Dex metadata file.
So let's take a look how
everything fits together from
the device perspective.  You
remember that I presented this
diagram in the beginning,
showing how
the profiling works locally.
Let's focus here just on the
profile on the application.
Once we will give, once we
manage to capture a profile
file, we are going to upload
this information to play.
On play, as I mentioned, we will
aggregate the data with many,
many other profiles.  When we
have a CORS headers profile we
are going to deliver it for new
users as a CORS headers profile.
The idea of the COR profile is
not to place on device.  It is
only for optimization.
Instead of starting with a
completed blank state about the
application, we
already know what are the most
commonly used paths and start
the optimization Z from there.
So now essentially what was a
pure
on-device profile, it is just
extended to the cloud
component.
Now, I keep talking about this
COR profile.
It is important to dedicate a
bit more attention to  it.  So
let's talk a bit how we are
going to build it.
We already know that on device
from one execution to the other,
the profile is aggregating quite
well.
They reach a safe point pretty
fast.  That means it will not
re-optimize the application over
and over and over again.
After a few optimization steps
we will stop.
However, the data from one
device, how well that works when
you try to do it across devices?
How many samples you will need
to order to get to a robust,
reliable profile?
We looked at our own Google
applications and tried to figure
that out.
Here you can see a plot which
represents the amount of
information in the core profile
relative to the total
number of obligations.
The Y axis represents the amount
of information and the actual
value, merit value is not
important there.  What is
important from this graph is
that actually from 20, 30 kind
of number of profile
aggregations, the information
in the profile reaches a
plateau.  And that is very
important.  It sends a very
important message.
It means that the alpha beta
channel uses will provide us
with enough data to build a CORS
headers  profile.
It means the majority of the
profile users of your
application will always
have the best possible
experience.
So how do we actually aggregate
the information?
I mentioned before that in the
profile
you will find information about
classes and method.  On device
this is roughly how it looks
like.  We are going to take all
the executions that we have seen
before and we will create a
union of everything that is
seen.
In the aggregated profile you
will have information about
classes, methods
about everything that you've
seen.
On cloud, however, we don't
really want everything.
We only want the common executed
path and what we are doing
instead of having a union, we
will be having a smart
intersection.  We will be only
keeping the information relevant
to all executions.
Meaning we are going to
filter out all the outliers.
The result is what we call the
COR
profile which only keeps the
most common samples.  That is
what is going to get eventually
to the device.
How well does this work?
Let's look again at data
captured from Google app.
We look at this across a variety
of applications and here are
some representative ones.
In this step you can find
examples on native code, for
example Google camera.
Or applications which have are
much more Java oriented.
Say Google maps or Google Docs.
For Google camera, for example,
you
get startup time improvement of
12.6 percent which is excellent
even if the application itself
doesn't have a lot of Java code.
However for maps or docs,
heavily Java based you can see
the optimizations
improves the startup time by
about 28 percent or 43 percent.
Across the border you can see
an average of about 20 percent
improvement and that obviously
depends on what the application
is doing, how much Java code is
being used and so on.
Now, I mentioned in the
beginning that besides improving
the application
performance directly via profile
guided optimization, the profile
offers much more opportunities.
I am going to present a short
use case study and walk you
through some important aspects
that the profile can reveal
about your application.
During the use case study I'm
going to focus on a single
question:  Are you
shipping unnecessary code to the
client?
Are you?
Let's take a look at some
data.
Again, this case study reflects
the
state of some Google.
On profile we average 14, 15
percent
of the code and 85 percent of
the code remains unprofiled.
When you spread the
distribution, for example, some
maps five to 10 percent of
the code gets profiled and some
others 60 percent of the code
gets profiled.
This is a rather intriguing
result.
And the reason for that is that
if the
code is not  profiled, most
likely that means that it might
not have been execute the.
Obviously that is for a good
case.  I mean, the code, for
example, can be unexpected error
codes path, right?
We all want the applications to
be reliable and robust and the
error handling must be there.
Hopefully it never gets
executed.  You may have backward
compatibility code, support for
previous API level and such.
You may have features which are
not
used on all devices and have
very features targeted.
And you might also have a lot of
unnecessary code lying around.
Maybe including libraries that
you don't really use.  Now, it's
a bit hard to breakdown the
percentage for this categories.
There can be other reasons why
we didn't profile the code.
But the key distribution here is
a strong indication there is a
lot of room for improvement for
APK.
The code can be reorganized or
cleaned down for better
efficiency.
For example, Google Play
introduced dynamic delivery
scheme which may help you reduce
the code that you share by
targeting features only to
certain users and that's
something you might want to look
at and take advantage of.
So we believe that there is
quite a bit of unnecessary code
lying around, at
least in our own APK.  Now,
since we focused on the code
that  actually doesn't get
profiled, is there
anything that we can extract out
of the profile code?
To understand this, let me talk
a bit about different categories
of profile code.  When the
application code is being
profiled, the Runtime will try
to label it depending on its
state.  It will have a label for
the startup category.  For the
post startup category and for
the hot category.  Obviously
these are self-explanatory.  The
hot category of the code is
essentially what the Runtime
deems to be the most important
part of your code.
It is important to keep in mind
that these are not disjoined.
Say, for example, that the
method  Fu
is being skewed, either during
startup
or executed during post startup
time and also marked as hot, for
example if you
have very heavy usage during
that method.
If you know the code executed
during startup time, if you
focus on that you will be able
to lower the startup time of the
application.
That is the impression that your
users will have of your
application will be very good.
If you start with the post
startup
code that will help you lay out
the Dex bicode.  That will lead
to memory improvement and much
smoother on the device.
But for the hot code, this is
the code that should get the
most attention
for your optimization efforts.
It is the code that is most
heavy heavily executed by the
Runtime.  The Runtime deems it
is very beneficial using that
time there.  For  example, if
you start with that, you try to
improve the quality and
performance of your app, this is
where
you should spend your effort,
initial effort.
This is important, how much of
your code is actually being
marked as hot.
If everything is  hot, then
everything can be optimized,
which is not really useful.
Let me show you the breakdown of
these three categories.
In this graph, you can see on
the red
column the percentages for the
profile code and the not profile
code.
This will sum up to 100 percent
and it is what I showed you
earlier.  They are here just for
references.  The blue boxes show
the percentages of
the startup code, the post
startup code
and hot one relative to the Dex
bicode.  Don't expect it to add
to 100 percent.  One piece of
code can be in different
categories at the same time.
As you can see here, the
average, on average about 10
percent of the
application Dex bytecode is
being marked as hot.  This
indicates that when you focus on
your app optimization, you can
dedicate attention only starting
with just a small part of your
application code base.
Obviously if you spend time on
all the
other parts as well, but this is
where you should start from.
With this let me go over a quick
review of what we presented
today.
And the main benefits.
We started with Kotlin and we
described few optimization s we
added that focused on Kotlin
performance.  We described
briefly how we approach Kotlin
optimizations and that we first
tried to seek improvement in the
Kotlin compiler.
We moved to memory and storage
optimizations.
My colleague Matthew introduced
you to the concept of exact
desks.
This is a new Dex format
available just on device and
focuses on the memory saving.
And finally, I presented you
the idea of cloud profile.  And
we talk about how we can
bootstrap
the profile guided optimizations
using a
small percentage of alpha beta
channel users in order to lead
important performance
improvements right after
start time for the majority of
the production  users.
With this I would like to thank
you for your attention and four
your presence.
And I want to invite you all to
Android Runtime office hours
tomorrow where we can answer any
questions you have about today's
presentation or Runtime in
general.
We are going to be half past 5
in section A.
Thank you so much.
(Applause.
)
(Music playing.
>> ANNOUNCER: Thank you for
joining this session.
Brand ambassadors will assist
with through the designated
exits.  We will make room for
those who registered for the
next session.  If you registered
for the next session in this
room we ask that you clear the
room and return to the
registration line outside.
Thank you.
(The session concluded.
)
The Stage 2 session Drawn Out:
How
Android Renders the UI will
begin in approximately 13
minutes.
)
(Music playing.
(Standing by for the GOOGLE I/O
Stage 2 session Drawn Out: How
Android Renders the UI.
)
(Music playing.
>> ANNOUNCER: At this time,
please find your seat.
Our session will begin soon.
(The session is about to begin.
)
>>> hi, welcome to our talk four
Drawn Out: How Android Renders
the UI.
Somebody in some position
decided it was  actually going
to be called how to optimize
your app for top rendering
performance or something.  That
wasn't what the talk was about.
We changed it back.  Instead we
are going to tell you the
details of how actually stuff
works.
I'm Chet Haase from the Android
toolkit and I'm Romaine guy.  I
do realtime graphics.
>> CHET HAASE: That is kind
of what we are doing that.  We
have given ergs veries of this
talk before and thought we were
done and realized enough stuff
has changed inside the system,
maybe it's time to go through
this again and see where we're
at.
This is our attempt to do that.
Let's go.
So first of all there is this
word rendering.  What do we mean
by that?
Normally it means melting fat in
order to clarify it.  That is
not what we are talking about.
We are talking about the actual
process of turning the check
boxes and everything into pixels
that users can look at.  There
are a lot of details we are
glossing over today because we
only have 40 minutes to do this.
But we'll dump a lot of
details on you along the way.
First of all, I'm going to
take you through.  There will be
a bunch of colored dots
on the top, a visual cue for the
rest of
the talk m I'll walk through the
life of what happens to the flow
of pixels on the screen.  We
have the choreographer.
That kibes in usually 60 times a
second and says hey, Vsync this
is the interval at which the
frame is being synced.  Buffers
flip on to the screen.  It's a
good time for us to process a
lot of information and handle
rendering that information as a
result of that.
We get a Vsync operation.
That is sent up to the Java DSM
land and we are on the UI
thread.  All of a sudden we need
to process input events
triggering changes in
properties.
We need to run anti-animation.
That may trigger things like
layout and validation.
We do the whole Traversal path,
measuring views to see how large
they are, laying them out,
positioning them where they need
to be and drawing them.  Once
all of that information is done
we sync the result of that
information over to the thing
called the render thread.
And the render thread takes
that and
says, okay, I'm going to then
execute these.
I'm going to basically turn
these into native versions of
all that information we produced
at the Java layer and going to
get a buffer from the GPU so I
have a place to write this
information.  Then I'm going to
actually issue all
these GPU commands, the OpenGL
stuff over there.  I swap the
buffer and turn it over to the
GPU and the graphic system does
something called compositing.
>> ROMAIN GUY: Compositing
is something we never explained
before.  We will go know a
little bit of detail about this
part of the rendering
architecture.
>> CHET HAASE: The colored
dots on the top of the screen
will be denoting where we are in
the process as we work through a
few examples.
Here is a simple example.
Suppose that we have a user and
the user clicks on an item.  I
wrote this awesome recycler view
application that looks exact lie
like this.  I know it is because
that's a screen shot from my
awesome application.
It is a recycler view with a
bunch of items in it.
When the user clicks on one an
amazing thing happens.
It turns to a random color on
the background.  It's
incredible.  I could give you
the source but it's complicated.
I'm not sure you would
understand it.
Here is the layout.
There is a constraint lout, a
recycler view and populated in
Runtime with random items in
there.
The view hierarchy looks
basically like this.  No,
exactly like this.  You work
down from the deCOR view and you
have the framelayout, I'm not
sure why we have the deep
nesting there, whatever history.
We have a bunch of stuff for
action bar in there.  None of
that matters.  What we are
concerned about here, what is
actually going in the content
hierarchy.  That's what you can
affect with your application.
We have constraintlayout and
all of the items, specifically
these are the items on screen
because those are the only ones
that are actually being measured
and laid out and drawn.
All right.  So what happens?
Let's walk through this example
and walk through the entire flow
that we went through at the
beginning.  User clicks.
There's a Vsync operation.  That
gets sent up.  We process input.
During the input phase we notice
that this is a click.  I'm
glossing over details here.
Actually we will notice first
there was a down and then an up
and then processed as a click.
Take it for granted eventually
we are going to process a click
here.
That ends up in this item click
methods I have in this amazingly
complex example.  We are going
to set the background color to a
random color.  That's why I
called the method random.
That gets sent over to the set
background color in Java that
does a
bunch of stuff to set the color
on the pack ground drawable and
calls this railed date.
Invalidation is a process, it
doesn't redraw the views.
It's telling the view hierarchy
that something needs to be
redrawn.
So you get a click.
That happens on the item down at
the bottom.  So that item 2, you
see it surrounded by green.  We
have a little invalidate method
that gets called on that.  That
basically walks up the tree.
Calls a series of methods all
the way up the tree.
The view knows that it needs to
be redrawn but to propagate that
information all the way up the
hierarchy so we can redraw all
the things on the way down
later.
We call invalidate child all the
way
up the hierarchy ending up in a
massive
class we have called U root
input.Java.  We have the child
there which does nothing except
say I need to schedule a
Traversal, which means I got
information that somebody
invalidated somewhere.
That means I need to run my
Traversal code later in the
process.
Traversal is the process of
doing all of the phases
necessary for actuallying
rendering that frame.
Specifically it does measure,
how big
the views are; lay out, setting
the
views, position and size, and
draw the views, scheduling a
Traversal.
That will happen at some
later time and that later time
is now.  In the same frame we
end up in the Traversal code in
this perform Traversals method.
It is going to do a perform draw
which
ends up calling a draw view on
to core view and that will
propagate all the way down.  The
draw method actually ends up in
an
optimization that we implemented
back in.
>> ROMAIN GUY: Honeycomb?
>> CHET HAASE: A display
list which stores the rendering
information.  If you look at the
way the button code is written
or view code in general we
call graphics commands in van
vast, I don't know, drawable,
draw a line or whatever, but
these end up as operations in a
display list.  This is a compact
way of representing those
operations as well as the
parameters through the
operations.
So we call get display list.
The DecorView did not change.
It is going to say I didn't
change but I can certainly get
the display list from my child
and all the way down the tree
until it gets to item two and
says oh, I did change.  When
invalidate was called on me that
triggered something so I know I
need to redraw myself.
Get display list is a draw view
so it generates its own display
list.
It ends up in the draw method
and that ends up in the display
list for that.
For this item, basically react
information and text information
and pretty basic.  We have the
display list for the entire
hierarchy.  It wasn't just the
view itself but we
have the view hierarchy itself
is in the display list all the
way down.  We have the display
list for the entire tree.
That's all we need to do on the
UI thread.
We need to sync that to the
render thread, a separate thread
actually dealing with the GPU
side of this operation.  On the
Java side we produced all the
information.  On the native side
we  actually produce, we take
that information and sync it
over to the GPU.
So we have the sync operation
where basically we copy a handle
over there.  And we also copy
some related information.  We
copy the damage area because it
is important to know that that
item 2, that's the only thing
that changed during that frame,
which means we don't need to
redraw anything else outside of
that area.  We need to copy over
the clip bounds there so we know
what needs to be redrawn.  We
are also going to do some
optimization stuff like
uploading bitmaps.
This is a good time to do it at
the beginning of the frame, give
those time to turn that into.
>> ROMAIN GUY: We are
uploading the non-hardware bit
map, a new type of
bitmap which was done on Android
O.  When it comes time to draw
we have to make a copy of the
bitmap on the GPU.  This takes
extensive time.
We are using the hardware maps
available in Oreo.  You can skip
the Java side of the equation
and have a bitmap that lives
only onment GPU.
If you never modify the bitmap
again
this is a efficient way to store
your bitmaps on the memory.
>> CHET HAASE: We mentioned the
render threld.
There is native code, no call
outs to application code or
Java.  It just talks to the GPU.
We did this first in Lollipop.
We did something we did
pre-render thread.
We display listed the
information and we send the
display list information to the
GPU.  It is sort of serial.
The render thread is able to do
something automatically like
circular
reveal as well as ripple
animations and render drawable
informations can happen on the
render thread.  Something that
can happen without installing
the UI thread.  The UI thread
can do things after it
is idle, like some of the idle
prefect for the render view that
was done last year.
Render thread kicks in.  We
synced everything, have the
display list and damage area.
We turn the display list into
something we called DL ops.
Display list operations.  So you
can see that we have that fill
operation in the middle.  That
is the thing that we turned
green there.
And then we have some
optimizations that we performed.
>> ROMAIN GUY: We have
various optimization Z.  For
instance if you do alpha
rendering or if you set hardware
layer on the view we try to
identify the drawing commands
that need to be targeted to
those layers and move them at
the beginning of the frame.
These do state changes inside
the CPU which are extremely
expensive.  Without doing this
kind of optimization you would
see horrible performance.  Not
because the GPU itself will be
slow.  It will be waiting for
the CPU to give it instructions.
The other one we are going to do
next is real story and matching.
You can look in this example
because
we have a list of item we
interleave a lot of things that
are similar.
We are going to draw text and
draw a rectangle in text again.
We are changing the state of the
GPU several times but if the
comments don't overlap we can
draw all the triangles and text
together.
This is part of the realtime
batching.  If we look at a bunch
of text that is the same color
and font, they don't have to be
different draw text calls.
It can be similar ones that
cover the entire screen.
>> CHET HAASE: You can see
here, the
entire fill ops has text which
will end
up being render text copies from
the mip catch.
It has text and fill and text
and fill and all of these
operations interlaid.  Then we
have a series of fills and a
series of text operations.  They
can even be  batched together to
be more optimal which we will
see here.
>> ROMAIN GUY: This is an
example of Gmail that was in the
Honeycomb era.  You can see we
modified the pipeline to slow
down the rendering and this is
how Gmail was drawing.  We draw
they will in the exact order
that they exist in the hierarchy
in your code actually like all
the draw calls that you make on
canvas or respective otherment
unfortunately like I said it is
very inefficient.  After
batching and merging and
rendering we get this.
You can see in particular
that all the stars were drawn at
the same time.  And most of the
text appear all at once.  What
is interesting is we are drawing
all the list item bag grounds
one after the other.  That is
good, the reordering worked.
The batching didn't work partly
because the items are slightly
overlapping.
When comments overlap we have to
make sure that the alpha views
are correct.  And in so the
effect really depends on the
application.
If I remember correctly in
KitKat the settings application
was, we could dru the whole
screen in about six draw calls
instead of dozens and dozens as
seen by the view hierarchy.
This was important for us.
>> CHET HAASE: This work on
today's devices saves a
millisecond which doesn't sound
like much until you realize we
have to do everything in 16.
There was a huge improvement
that caused Android not to be as
janky.
Now we have the clip reject.
Now we feed in the information
about the damage area.  So we
know where item 2 was on the
screen and we know we don't need
to draw anything outside of
that.  As we are processing the
DL ops we know we can throw away
anything that is drawing outside
of that area.  And in graphics
that is called a trivial reject.
We trivially reject all the DL
ops not intersecting with that
area.
We need to draw some fill and
text and a line.
We do that.
In the process of doing that we
do a get buffer.  This is an
implicit operation.  We don't
request a buffer.  As soon as we
start doing GPU operations, the
GPU hands us the buffer, more
particularly the Surface layer
hands us the buffer.
We issue the commands.  This is
a series of GL commands.
As you can see on the slide it
says GL commands, basically the
equivalent of what we need for
doing the fill or the text,
bitmaps, copies, lines,
whatever.
We swap the buffer.  So this is
us saying we are done with all
of our rendering operations.  We
are ready to display this frame
on
the screen at the request of
Surface Flinger.  We are done
drawing with the buffer, you can
swap with the one in front and
it will put it on the screen.
Meaning while in Surface flapper
which Romaine will talk about
layer but it takes all of the
Windows on the screen.  We see
the navigation bar, status bar
and actual content window for
our combination.
It combines those in the
compositor, pullets it on the
screen and ta-da, we're done.
That was a simple example.
Let's look at a super
complicated example.  This is in
two phases.  We are going to
drag the list up.  Drag it and
as we drag it we are going to
move the items a little bit.
Eventually if we keep moving
them we have a new item appear.
We will look at two versions of
this.  There is the move only
version.
As we drag it up, a -- not a new
item appears.  Everything shifts
a little bit up.
First of all we need to
process the down.
So we have a Vsync that says
time to process input  events.
We do that and we end up in code
like
this on touch event in recycler
view it says there was a down
operation.  All it needs to do
is register where that down
happened.  It doesn't need to
process anything.  Nothing
changed on the screen.  We
registered that the user
actually pressed down.  We
record that for later.  There is
no auth, we don't do anything of
the rest of the stuff we talk
about because nothing changed.
All right.  They keep
dragging.  We end up in similar
code.  We process input on the
next frame.  Okay, on touch
event.  We know that they
actually moved.  We know how
much they moved because we saved
the old X and Y and we will
calculate the delta.  Now we
call this thing called off set
top and bottom.  Basically for
all the screws on the
screen we simply move them in Y.
Offset top and bottom, it is an
invalidation odd tho to do but
slightly different.  Invalidate
view property.  This is an
optimization we put in in
probably Honeycomb second
release or something with
display list properties.
When I talked about display
lists earlier there was a Nuance
I left out.  We have the
information about the operations
and parameters for the  graphics
operations but we have
information about some core
display list properties which
are basically properties of the
view like translation property,
rotation, alpha.  These are
properties which we don't need
to re-render the view to
change.  We can simply change
them in the display list
structure itself.  They get
picked up at GPU issue time.  It
is a very fast operation to do
that.  Instead of revalidating
everything in that view all we
say is change the translation
property in that view.  The way
that happens is, we call
invalidate view property.  That
propagates all the way up the
tree.  We need to know at the
top layer what happens, but it
is a much more optimal step.
This ends up in scheduled
Traversals
as it did before in the draw,
ends up in perform Traversals,
but perform draw can do more of
this because the display list
didn't change.  We only changed
display list products NTS of it.
We can sync that over to the
render threads and execute that,
turn that into display list ops,
get the buffer.  Basically
everything is as before.
All right, let's go through
the second phase of that super
complicated example.  User keeps
dragging.  As they drag, a new
item respect respect as on the
bottom.
Vsync, process the inspot, end
up with a method like this.  We
know they moved.  That means
that we need to trigger the
creation and the bind of that
new item there.  That ends up in
code like this where we actually
add a view to the parent.
The recycler view is going to
get a new view, going to call
requestlayout.  Requestlayout is
kind of like invalidation.
Instead of saying I need to be
redrawn, it says I need to be
remeasured and relayed out.
That could side effect everybody
there.  We basically propagate a
requestlayout up the tree like
invalidation and do measure and
lay out on the entire tree to
see what happened there.
Requestlayout happens on the
parent and propagates all the
way up.
And that ends up again in
schedule Traversals, our
friends.  Then perform
Traversals, not talking about
the draw stuff now.  We are
going to do a perform measure
and perform lay out.  It is
asking all of the views how big
they would like to be.   It's a
request.
Layout says this is how big you
are going to be and this is
where you are going to be
positioned.  It is a negotiation
between the views and their
parents according to all of the
con traints in the system.
We do a perform measure that
basically calls measure at the
top and that propagates all the
way down and then we have all
the information about how big
all the views want to be.  And
that is good enough for us to
calculate the layout informs and
we propagate layout all the way
down the tree.  Once that
happens on the item and the
parent that changed, we actually
lay out that item and we are
ready to go.  Now we can
actually draw things and
everything is as before.
So the Nuance here was just
the lay out size except an
important Nuance is
we are talking about all of this
requestlayout and measure
happening for
this recycler information,
however recycler view optimizes
in.  It knows enough about
parent and children that it can
offset the views instead of
doing the requestlayout it
can move the items out of the
way.  So this is for the request
view as
well as the older list view.
>> ROMAIN GUY: Now suffers
Flinger compilation posits all
the views on the screen.
This it is always interesting to
run something new in technology
and you
understand some of the
philosophies behind Surface
texture or the immediate code.
Before we can understand
composition
we have to understand a very
important concept called the
buffer cue.
The BufferQueue is just a queue
of buffers, where graphics
buffers live.  Typically we have
one to three buffers, different
options internally.  When we set
it up we can request how many we
want.
Very importantly a BufferQueue
has two  endpoints, the producer
and consumers.  The way we use a
BufferQueue, the
producer calls a method called,
it grabs the buffer from the
queue and owns it.
It can be setting the pixel
data,
using  OpenGL, canvas, doesn't
matter.
This is what happens when you
call
sweat buffers at the end when we
are producing content inside the
buffer.  When the producer is on
producing the
content, he calls it and gives
it back to the BufferQueue.  The
consumer can grab the next
buffer in the view yiewrg
acquire.  He calls acquire
buffer.  Takes the first buffer
in the queue, does whatever
needs to be done with it and
when he's done he puts it back
by calling release.
So it is a pretty simple
concept.  Of course if you were
to look at the
code all the header files, it's
pretty complicated in part
because the two ends of the
BufferQueue can live in
different processes.
This is exactly what happens
with our Surface compositor
works.  When you create a window
in the system, you have a
manager and Surface Flinger.
The manager is the producer in
the
sneer and Surface Flinger is the
Megger.  This is what is done
automatically for
you when you create a activity.
Internally we create a window
object.  That has a sibling on
the Surface Flinger side called
a layer.  The names can be
confusing because in graphics we
have to deal with buffers and
queues and that's all we do and
we quickly run out of names.
The graphics team, we have
Surface and
Surface text you ares and layer
and so it's a little bit messy.
We have a layer, basically a
window.
And the layer is the confidence
in the system that creates and
owns of the BufferQueue for
your.
We have a way to send then
points by creating a Surface.
Whenever you see a Surface in
one of the APIs you have the
producer end point
of a BufferQueue that lives
somewhere else in the  system,
your process or
some other O.
Most of time in the Surface
Flinger.
As a developer, you are going to
deal
with the Surface -- with the
Surface view.
The window, we cut a hole
through the
surface and ask the window
manager and Surface Flinger to
create a new Surface and we
pretend they are part of the
same window but they are not.
They are two different surfaces,
two different Surface views and
completely independent from one
another.  If you use a Surface
view you are
going to use OpenGL or Vulkan or
media player.  In this case we
have GIS.
It is going to call a buff, do
rendering, and go back into the
BufferQueue.
If you use a Surface texture, so
your  producer -- sorry, the
consumer will be OpenGL.  So you
create a surface texture by
giving it a texture ID.
In that case the surface texture
creates and owns the Surface
view.  This will often be in
your other than process.  You
have to pass that to some
producer.  To do this you create
the end points yourself by
creating a surface.  There's a
construct of surface that takes
the surface  texture.  You
create your surface.  You send
it to some other application.
And then when you OpenGL code is
ready
to render it calls acquire to
get the buffer from the
BufferQueue.  It does the
rendering   and itself produces
a buffer inside another queue
and when it's done it can call
re-east.
Texture view is the widget
that is
part of a UI tool that you can
use for Surface texture.
The render that we talked about
is the consumer of the Surface
texture.  You are responsible
forgetting the
texture from the view and give
it to a producer of your choose.
Think of it as an image view
that you
can update efficiently using
hard works.  In recent years we
used to tell you that texture
view was the solution instead of
Surface view when you wanted
to integrate a video or OpenGL
rendering
inside the complex, once you
have a list view or card view or
anything animated because it was
made of two different Windows
twat not efficient for that and
not synchronized with your own
application.  This has been
fixed in recent  versions of
Android.  Most of the time you
should use Surface view instead
of texture view.
Use texture view only when you
are SAN switched  between --
>> CHET HAASE: I think it was
the O release.
>> ROMAIN GUY: O or N. We have
to test.
>> CHET HAASE: But recent.
>> ROMAIN GUY: Here is a
list of consumers and users in
the platform.  Open GIS is a
producer.  It can also be a
consumer.  Remember when Chet
was says saying that in the
lifecycle of a frame at some
point we get a buffer, that's
when we call DC buffer from the
thread.  This is done when we do
the first draw call.
When with he call the driver
that we are done with the frame
it will produce the frame and
put it back in the BufferQueue.
You can use like Vulkan, media
player and code deck.  Many
others.
We have created multiple windows
that have their own layer.
Surface Flinger knows about
those.  They talk to something
called the hollow composer, a
hardware abstraction layer that
we use because we want to avoid
using the GPU.  When we need to
composite all the windows on
screen.  One is to save battery,
more efficient that way.  But we
want to make sure you have
access to all of the capability
of the GPU.  We don't take it
away from you.
In pass we heard you should
limit the number of windows on
the screen and you'll see why in
a few slide.
We have a block of hardware that
is
really fast, multiple bitmaps
and come pot iting them on the
screen.  We talked about this.
The way it looks, the hollow
composer is a protocol.
I will explain the hollow
composer,
now we use hollow composer two
which is more complicated.  I
won't describe it but it
basically works the same way.
Surface Flinger has a bunch of
layers.
We are going to call compare and
send all the layers to the
hollow composer
and ask it what it wants us to
do with each layer.
It is a proprietary piece of
freer in the phone or tablet you
are using.
We can't write to all the
drivers for
-- in this case we have a layer,
the
hole low will composer writes
overlay, understanding the pixel
format of that window an tells
us that it can handle it and do
the composition for that window.
It is telling us overlay for the
second and third layer.  That is
great.  All the composition can
be done automatically for us on
our behalf in an efficient way.
All our layers are matched to
overlays we call set.
We send all the hollow composer
for actual come pongs and the
hollow composer sends everything
to the screen.
More complex example.  We have a
number of  layers we prepare.
For the first one everything
goes fine.
Hollow composer says overlay, it
can handle it.
The next one it stays (?).  It
could be because you are using
rotation and the hollow composer
doesn't know how to handle
rotation or we have too many
layers on the screen or any
number of reasons that are
specific to that hollow
composer.
>> CHET HAASE: This was more
common
to devices three or four or
longer years ago.
>> ROMAIN GUY: We used to have
four hardware layers you could
use.  That's five -- that's
four.
On pixel 2, without going into
too much detail, you have
basically seven.  Much better
than it used to be.
If you have a pixel 2XL, we use
two of
those layers to draw those round
Karen corners.  You don't have
seven, you have five.  Lots of
dates, complicated.
You don't need to know the
details.
We have one -- we have two
layers that are frame buffer.
That is where the hard part
starts for
us because when we have layers
that are not handled by the
hollow composer we
need to use the GPU to compose
them ourselves.
In this situation we need to
create basically a scratch
buffer, another layer in a
format that we know the hollow
composer can accept.
And then we use custom OpenGL
code to do the composition
ourselves of those two layers.
Then once we are done with that
part we are left with only two
layers.  We know that those can
(?).  So that's what we do.  We
call set and then issue up on
the screen.
>> CHET HAASE: If you are
curious,
sometime you can run this
command, AB
shell dump as Surface Flinger.
>> ROMAIN GUY: Capital S,
capital F.
>> CHET HAASE: Important.
It will spill out more
information than you want but it
will show you a table of the
windows on the screen and
whether they are currently
represented as overlays or frame
buffer.
>> ROMAIN GUY: You have to
run this comment quickly because
there are tons of optimization Z
internally.  What can happen is
if layers have been on the
screen for awhile and we know
they are not changing, the
hardware
composer may be collapsing them
into a single layer.  The output
is sometimes list misleading.
You may see the result of
optimization s based on time.
Usually you should run this when
you are running animation or
something is changing on the
screen, that will be the most
valuable information for you.
A few other things we.
Talked about.
We used to tell you to use the
invalidate, only part of your
view that you knew needed to be
repainted.
This was with older Android
voices because ...
Early in the early days of
software rendering, we were
maximumming out the GPU.  Those
were important savings.  You
don't need to do this anymore.
On recent versions of Android
before, this was  actually
ignored by the system.  What
happens, every time you go
invalidate or invalidate with
rectangle
with the view, the renderer will
recompute that area and you
don't have to worry about it.
Not only is it not necessary
anymore for savings but also
because it is error prone.
Easy to have a rendering error
and get (indiscernible) on the
screen.  Chet and I fixed so
many bugs linked to the use of
those APIs and the framework
itself still has bugs around
that.  Now you don't have to
worry about it.
Recycler view will do
pre-fetching of items ahead of
time.
>> CHET HAASE: We mentioned
this earlier.  This is one of
the wins we are having from
having a separate render thread.
There is idle time.  Renderer
was done with the work after the
sync.
It can use that time
productively for fetching things
that it knows it might need in
the next few frames.
>> ROMAIN GUY: We have a
concept of actual display, there
is an API you can use, for
example when we take a screen
shot or record a video or when
we do casting, Chrome casting,
for instance.
What we are effectively doing is
asking suferg Flinger to display
to another surface, another way
of producing a Surface.  If you
are interested there is a
sample application of graphicka.
Written by the graphics team
from a few years ago, a
collection of things
that you can do with the media
encoder, with Surface view, an
interesting piece of code to
look at.  Color transform, in
Android O, we induced color
management.  That is one of the
transforms we can
apply, things like night light,
also color transforms, we have
color blind installation.  Those
can be handled by the hollow
composer in specific situations
and it
can be the cause for performance
issues.  For instance, awhile
back, night light
was not supported, I believe, on
the N5X or N6P.  One of the
reason, the hardware, the
drivers that could do the color
transform, we had to fall back
to GPU,
it was sense I have, hurting the
battery.
There are many more details
about the rendering.  This is a
high level overview.
We give a number of talks in the
past that explain in more
details what we do, for
instance, in the UI renderer
itself, how we do the batching,
merging.  If you are
interested.
>> CHET HAASE: Shadow
calculation is interesting.  We
have a talk where we talk about
those details.  Where does it
fit in the rendering pipeline is
every clever.  Yes, lots more
going on there.  Hopefully this
gives you a general sense of how
things work on Android.
>> ROMAIN GUY: With that we are
done.  We may have time for one
question?
>> ROMAIN GUY: If you have a
question you can walk to one of
the mics?
After that we will have to run
away from here to go to our next
session.
>> CHET HAASE: Yes. Doesn't
look like it.
>> ROMAIN GUY: No questions?
>> CHET HAASE: I think we're
done.
>> ROMAIN GUY: Oh, one
question.
>> CHET HAASE: You just wanted
to build a little suspense.
>> ROMAIN GUY: I was afraid
that everything we said was
clear.
>>Audience: Hi.
The question is, in Android
performance you had a suggestion
that we
have to have no more than two
and a half layers of overlay.
One view is above another and so
on.  Is it a problem now?  What
is --
>> CHET HAASE: That's the
point we were talking about
earlier.  On older devices
certainly in the
Honeycomb area all prevalent
devices had four overlays.  It
was easy to flip into that
situation.
>> ROMAIN GUY: Talking about
overlays or over draw.
>>Audience: Sorry, I mean over
draw.
>> ROMAIN GUY: Bandwidth has
not really increased.
Now all the GPUs we have are
called tires and blending is
actually fast on the GPU.  So
over draw is not as important as
it used to be.
I wouldn't worry about it too
much.  If you see performance
issues, take a look at that and
zoo if it is an issue.  Over
draw is interesting to look at
not because of the rendering
performance, but maybe you are
doing too many views or too much
in general.  It is something to
look at, but it is not the most
important thing you should be
looking at.
>> CHET HAASE: We have to run
to the next talk.  We will stop
it there.  Thank you.
(Applause.
)
(Music playing.)
>> ANNOUNCER: Thank you for
joining this session.  Brand
ambassadors will assist with
directing you through the
designated exit.
We will be making room for those
who registered for the next
session.  If you registered for
the next session in this room we
ask that you please clear the
room and return via the
registration line outside.
Thank you.
(Music playing.)
(The session concluded.)
(Please stand by for the
GOOGLE I/O 2018
Stage 2 session The Future of
the Android App Model and
Distribution on Google Play.
)
(Music playing.
(Standing by for the GOOGLE I/O
2018 Stage 2 session The Future
of the Android App Model and
Distribution on Google Play.
)
(The 5:00 o'clock Stage 2
session will begin in
approximately ten minutes.
Standing by.
)
(The GOOGLE I/O 2018 Stage 2
session The Future of the
Android App Model and
Distribution on Google Play will
begin momentarily.  Please
continue to stand by.
)
>> ANNOUNCER: At this time,
please find your seat.  Our
session will begin soon.
(Music playing.
)
(Standing by for the GOOGLE I/O
2018 Stage 2 session Build the
Nw Modular Android App Bundle.
)
(Standing by for the Stage 2
session The Future of the
Android App Model and
Distribution on Google Play.
) the Future of the Android App
Model and Distribution on Google
Play:  Build the New Modular
Android App Bundle.
)
(The session Build the New
Modular Android App Bundle is
about to begin.
)
>>> hi, everyone.
I'm Pierre and I'm a software
engineer on Google Play >>> hi,
everyone I'm Anthony, also a
software.
>>> I'm ib ham at Google.
>> PIERRE LECESNE: Some of.
>> ANTHONY MORRIS: This new
publishing format called.
We will do a technical deep
dive on the format and cover
what it contains, how to build
it, how to publish it but also
the different ways you can test
it.
We will also cover how Google
Play
conserves the APKs.
Let's start with the format of
the app bundle, it contains
everything you are familiar
with, Dex files and resources
assets, native libraries.
It is important to realize
that the
app bundle and APK weds are two
distinction formats.  The app
bundle is a publishing format
and cannot be  directly
installed on a device.
It also contains metadata files
that don't end up in the APKs.
They help them fill the APKs the
rate way.
The tools can fully understand
files
in the bundle so that it can
generate valid APKs.
Now, let's open up one App
Bundle and see what is inside.
If you open up an App Bundle
this is what you should expect.
So this should look familiar
to a lot of people.
Instead of reinventing the wheel
we decided to reuse Nevada the
structure of APK and only modify
what we needed to better
describe the file.  So we will
be free to go through them.
To start with, the App Bundle
has support for multiple modules
as you heard before.
We will tell you more about
modules shortly.  Know that the
top level directories in the App
Bundle are the names of the
modules.
There is always a module named
base in the bun and that's what
we are looking at here.
The Android manifest is still
project.  It is a real XML file.
In the APKs it is binary and in
the
App Bundle is is compiled so we
can transform it more easily.
As opposed toe APK, the Dex
files are
under directory name Dex.
The resources, assets and
libraries follow the same
directory structure as in APK.
The only difference are the XML
resources which are also
compiled into a
protocol format instead of the
binary format.
The file resources is the
resource table, the equivalent
of the resources that you have
seen in your APKs.  It describes
the resources present in your
app and targeting.  The.
.pb extension makes it easier
for tails
to format before transformed
positive APK.
The native files are the
equivalent of the resource table
for assets and native libraries.
They only exist if you have
assets on native libraries and
describe the targeting of the
files in the respective
directories.
As I mentioned before, the
resource tables, the asset tail
and the native libraries table
describe the targeting of the
files of your app.  Let me
explain what it means by that.
Fun targeting is the
description of what type of
device or user a given file is
targeted for.
It is a trail concept in Google
Play dynamic delivery since
understanding the targeting of
files means we can serve to a
given user only the files they
need and this is what allows us
to make apps smaller.
The App Bundle reuses the
targeting that exists in packs.
You are already familiar with
this so I'll run through it
quickly.
Resources, we specify, for
example,
hdpi in the directory of your
devices.
Or add FR to target French
users.  On native libraries, it
is the same.  You add the
architecture to the directory.
Again, nothing new hearing.
The App Bundle works the same
way.
Now we realized that for some of
you, assets represent a big part
of your app.
So the App Bundle also supports
asset targeting.  We are
starting with language
targeting and we will soon we
added format and graphics
versions so we can serve only
the relevant assets to the users
and reduce further the size of
your apps and games.
This is how you would create a
targeted asset directory.
While making use of the hash
sign to
identify a directory that has
targeting.
Then comesment key, for example,
Lang
for the language, CCF for
compression format, et cetera
and then comes the value
associated with the key.
Let's see some examples.  Here
is an example of a directory
containing assets for users
speaking French.
This is another example of an
asset
directory targeted based on the
texture compression format.
Here targeting devices that
support
the far Matt  ETC1.
Now that you know more about
the
format I will hand it over to
Anthony
who tells you how we use this to
serve smaller apps for users.
Thoan hi thanks, Pierre.  Hi,
everyone.
I am going to explain to you how
we are changing the format of
what we serve to users and how
we use this to deliver only what
is needed for each user.
Now, we start with Split APKs.
Drew an droiled Lollipop we
added a feature called Split
APKs which allow multiple APKs
to be installed on a device and
behave as if they were part of a
single app.  The Split APKs can
be installed in different
combinations on different
devices and they can be
installed in one go up front or
piece-by-piece.
Now, a Split APK has the same
format as a normal pack.
They can contain Java code in
Dex
files, native code and resource
directories.
Once the  APKs are installed
they can act as a single APK.
Furthermore each Split APK says
the same package name and
version code with all the other
ones installed on the device and
must all be signed with the same
kit.
So now let's take a look at how
we
can take the Android App Bundle
and generate APKs that we then
serve to devices.
So we start by looking in the
App Bundle and finding
everything that is common to all
the  devices and putting those
in a base APK.  This would
include the Android Manifest
file and the Dex files, for
instance.
Then we generate a different
Split APK for each screen
density.  Each split will
contain all the drawables that
would have been selected by the
Android framework on a device
with that density.
We can also generate a
different Split APK for each
native architecture containing
native  libraries of that
architecture.
And we can generate a different
split for each language
supported by your app,
putting each language's strings
in a different APK.
Together we call these splits
configuration splits or config
splits.
Now when we go to serve an app
through a device we only need to
serve a subset of these splits
instead of serving everything to
every device.
Say I have a samsung Galaxy 5.
We install the base APK as well
as the
identity split, the ARM
infrastructure split and English
language split because I only
speak English.
It can get trickier.
Peer speaks both English and
French and specifies both
languaging the in addition to
the right density and
architecture split we serve both
the French and English language
split to his device.
Now, suppose Pierre then
moves to Brazil and learns
Portuguese.
He might add Portuguese as a ang
on his device.  When he does
this, the Play Store recognizes
this and will attempt to
download the Portuguese language
splits for all apps that use
splits on the device.
And if the device is not
online at the time, then we will
download those language splits
at the next opportunity.
So that is how config splits
work.
But as I mentioned at the start,
bits are only supported on
Lollipop and above.  That covers
85 percent of users at the
moment but most of you target
pre-L devices which is great.
These the App Bundle allows us
to achieve some of the savings
by achieving
stand alone APKs through --
instead of generating splits as
we would do for L
plus we do the (?) stand alone
APKs.  We considered the
language splits as well but did
some of the sums and it got out
of hand.
Now for pre-L devices we include
all
of the languages in all of the
pre-L APKs.
When we go to serve the app we
choose the best single APK for
the device.
If we have my first Android
tbais, the
Galaxyness sus, we serve the
stand alone ARM APK.  This is
similar to what you may have
done in the past with multiAPK.
Put this all together.  The
picture looks like this.  You
will actually don't need to
worry about the details about
how all these Split APKs are
generated or stand alone APKs
are generated.  All you have to
do is upload a single App Bundle
and play generates the right
splits and selects the right
ones to serve for each device.
And the dimensions we've
discussed so far are only the
beginning.  Pierre discussed how
the App Bundle lets you target
assets by graphics ape.
We will soon generate configure
IGT splits based on that.  We
will generate config splits that
take advantage of new platform
features
and uncompressed native
libraries on N plus devices.
I'll ask Ibo to come up and take
a
look at how much we can reduce
app size by reducing the App
Bundle.
(Applause.)
>> IBRAHIM KARAHAN: Thank you,
Anthony.
Let me know how play serves
Split APKs to your devices we
are going to talk about the size
savings with App Bundles.
We found out on average apps
published
with App Bundles are 20 percent
smaller.
And that is 20 percent savings
every time your application is
downloaded or upgraded.  Now,
let's look at how we reach to
this number.
We analyze all the
applications in Play Store with
more than 1 million downloads.
And we found out that for
strings we can save over 95
percent of their size by using
the language splits.
For images this is 45 percent.
And for native libraries, we can
save 20 percent of their sizes.
This means if every app were to
move to App Bundles we would
save
approximately
ten petabytes per day from app
downloads and upgrades.
300 million music videos on
YouTube.
On top of that, users could see
an
extra 300 megabytes of extra
disk space
for more photos, apps or more
music on their devices.
So now let's look at actual size
savings that are some of our
early access program and
partners.  We are going to start
with Twitter.
Twitter were already publishing
with multiAPKs before, with
architecture splits.
However, their application is
translated into a lot of
languages and
supports multiple screens.
They get less savings publishing
with
App Bundles decreasing 20
percent in
size and no longer serve
multiAPKs.
With App Bundles, they achieved
26 percent size savings across
all dimensions with app BUNs.
Jaumo's half is -- app is half
of the original size.  They have
a large library and supported
multiple architectures in a
single APK.
Now, let's look at how we can
build an App Bundle and you can
start saving now.
The latest Android studio 3.
2 Canary has possibility of
building now bun.
You see the options to build a
bun in the app menu.
We are going to select the App
Bundle, app module, product
flavor and build
type and Android studio is going
to create an App Bundle for you,
which is ready for publishing.
For those who prefer command
line or wish to integrate with
automated build
systems the new Android and
grade he
will plug in has tests to build
App Bundle.  Remember this is
what you use the assembled task
on the command line to create
the APK.  For App Bundles you
are going to
switch to the bun command,
similar to
the assemble tasks, bundles
allows us to
build a specific application of
-- of your application.  Once
the buns have finishes, it will
create in the output folder with
the fliefer understand build
type chosen.
The build architect is called
bundle dot IAB.
Build he will tasks are
compatible
with the  signing config in your
build dot Gradle files.
With a single Gradle task you
can produce files that are
signed and ready for publishing.
With app bundles play will
automatically split your
application into language splits
by default.  You don't need to
do any configurations.
However, this article wants to
have full control over the
splits.
So if for any reason you would
like to disable splitting by any
dimension you
can do so by using the newly
introduced bundle block here.
Now Pierre is going to talk
about how
to publish your app bundle in
the Play Console.
>> PIERRE LECESNE: Thanks, Ibo.
All right you have build an app
bunld em.  Let's look at how you
can publish it on Google Play
console.
First you must enroll in app
signing by Google Play.
For those who resh we launched
this at Google IO last year.
When enrolling you secure your
release key to Google Play.
Play then uses the release key
to sign
the generated APKs on your
behalf before serving them to
users.
But note that if you keep
uploading APKs on your
production track, while you test
the App Bundle in the test
track, play will not resign the
uploaded APKs.
We did this so you can feel
confident trying the App Bundle
on a small audience first
without affecting your current
production users.
Once you enrolled we can
manage the releases just hike
you did for APKs.  Create a new
release.
Drop the App Bundles in a
similar
location where you currently
drop APKs and watch the upload.
Once uploaded you can register
your release and roll it out.
That's it.
I can't stress enough, no more
multiAPKs to deal with.  Play
Console has created in the bag
ground all the APKs of the
supported devices for you.
Now, you have uploaded your
App
Bundle and play has done all the
heavy lifting for you.  Great.
Wouldn't it be nice to have an
overview of what play has
generated?  We have built a new
tool in Play
Console called bundle explorer
which
lets you navigate your uploaded
bundles.
Let's have a look on the first
screen
you can see at the top right
corner this size savings you
gained by publishing a bundle.
Here we saved over a quarter of
your app.  Of course this is
different by device.
So we clailted this using a
popular device configuration.
You will also find below the
list of device configurations
and the total size of the APKs
served to those devices.  Even
click on view devices and see
which devices are in each
bucket.
You can even search for any
supported device by name to
download the set of generated
APKs that is served to that
specific device.  This will be
super helpful when you get that
bug report on that specific
device and you want to get
exactly what the user has
gotten.  And what the APKs that
were served.  So you just search
for the name, click download and
you'll get the set of APKs that
play has served.
Of course, we have not forgotten
all of you who use our
publishing API.
Uploading App Bundles is
available using our API today.
You will find further
information at Google
gom/publisher.  I hand it over
to Anthony.
>> ANTHONY MORRIS: Thanks,
Pierre.  We learned how to build
and publish Android App Bundle
before we finalize we would like
to do a round of tech.  However,
we've seen that the App Bundle
on its own is not installable.
How do you test it?
First we note that during
development
you can install APKs built from
the App Bundle directly from
Android studio.  You don't need
to do anything here.
However, for QA teams we know
that they don't always have
access to the source code in
Android studio.
Let me take through Alice, Bob
and Claire and how they choose
to test with the QA team.
Start with Alice.
She uses the newly released
internal test track from the
Play Console.
The internal track is similar to
alpha and beta tracks that you
may already be familiar with.
But it differs in that there is
almost no delay between the
upload of the bundle and the
update being available on the
tester oh's device.
Quick turn arounds for your QA
testing.
Going through the Play Console,
Alice has the confidence that
what the QA team will receive on
their device is byte for byte
equal with what end users will
get
when you push your release to
production.
Let's see how Alice sets this
up.  Really  simple.
Alice creates a list of emails
of up
to 100 testers eligible for the
test track.  They are opt in at
length and now
receive the bundles uploaded to
the internal test track.  That's
it.
But we know that not all of
you have access to the Play
Console during your QA cycle.
Let's hear from Pierre about
Bob's story.
>> PIERRE LECESNE: Indeed, Bob
doesn't have access to the Play
Console.
He prefers also to testing
locally on his machine before
uploading anything.  But he
still wants to test what the
users will get.  How does he do
that?
Well, to generate APKs from the
bundle, play users a new tool
called bundle will too.  For Bob
to reproduce locally the build
he can simply download bundle
tool and write a few simple
commands.
Bundle tool has a comment
called
build APKs which takes Android
APK bundle and creates APK set
archive.  This is a collection
of APKs ready to be installed on
devices.
Another comment called install
APKs
tests that APK archive, extracts
the APKs and installs them on
this device.  Let's see some
real command line  work.
So here is the command by Bob
called
build petition, and where he
wants it to
be, by  passing -- build packs
just for the device  currently
connected to his machine.
And if Bob wants to generate
APKs for someone else on his
team without having the physical
device at hand he can still
provide a file that contains the
specifications of the device in
a JSON format and you can see
here an extract of such file
which provides the
information about the ABIs, this
device words, supported
languages, screen
density and the NTK version.
Bundle tool has a command to
generate
such file so you don't have to
find the device expect online or
don't have to write it yourself.
You run this command and it will
generate this command for you.
Also because Bob wants to
install the APKs on the device,
they need to be signed with a
private key.  He passes the path
to the key store.  All the APKs
contained in the APK set will
then be signed and directly
installable on Bob's device.
And here is the invocation of
the
install APKs comnld which
extracts the APKs and installs
them on the device.  Easy.
So that was Bob.  And his
local testing.
Now  Ibo will tell you Claire's
story.
>> IBRAHIM KARAHAN: Claire is
working for a medium sized
company.  And they set up a
continuous integration tool to
build their application.
Every day the create team holds
a nightly build of the
application, installs in
multiple devices and tests if
the application is working
correctly.
Claire wants to help the create
team and she uses the bundle
tool again to generate the APK
set in this  CI.
She uses a command that is very
similar to what Bob used
earlier, but
this time she omits the device
type flag
and she generates an APK set
which contains APKs for all
possible devices.
Now, the QA team will just grab
the APK set from the CI.
They run the install APKs
command.
Bundle tool will read the device
configuration from the attached
device,
will extract the APKs that
matches this
configuration from the APK set
and then install them on to the
device.  This is the same
selection that play does when
serving APKs for a given device.
One more thing that bundle
tool can
do is to generate a universal
APK by passing the universal
flag.
The universal APK is a single
APK that contains the file, all
the files for that matches all
the devices.
Because of that, it can be
installed in any device.
Well, it really doesn't
represent what your users will
receive when they install the
applications from Play Store.
However, this is a convenient
way to pass an APK to the user
when you don't know what device
they are running.
Bundle tool is also the tool
used to build Android App
Bundle.
And Gradle uses it behind the
scenes.  We are going to work
with the other build tool chains
to integrate build
tool so that you can build and
Android
App Bundle using any tool you
may be using.
Finally we want to be
transparent about how we
generate the packs we deliver to
your users, which is why we are
open sourcing bundle tool.  You
can go today to GitHub.
com/Google/bundle tool to
download an executable or build
it from the source.
Now, Pierre is going to talk
about another way to make your
applications even smaller.
>> PIERRE LECESNE: Thanks, Ibo.
With dynamic delivery we
introduce a new way to tbraik up
those into different features
and deliver only those for each
user.  Suppose you have a recipe
app and want to keep the initial
download small.  You observe
that while all your users
like to browse recipes, only a
small fraction choose to
actually add a new recipe.  You
notice that this functionality
takes up significant space in
your app.
What you can do is break that
feature out into its own module
and serve it only when needed.
We can see how it looks for a
user here.
Let's open the app.  When the
user wants to add a recipe, he
clicks a little plus on the
bottom
and you can see in the
background the module is
downloaded and installed.
And just after a few seconds,
the
module is ready to be used.
So which part of your app should
you break out as separate
features?
If only a small fraction of your
users use that feature, that
could be a good candidate,
especially if that feature takes
up significant space in your
app.
Finally, consider if your users
can wait a few seconds before
using the feature.
Once you've decided which
feature to create, this is how
it should look like in the App
Bundle.  In addition to the base
directory there are now separate
directories for each of the
modules of the app.  The format
of the directories is exactly
the same as the format of the
base that I covered earlier.
And this is the APKs display
that would be generated.
Each module has a set of sets
consisting of future splits and
config splits for that module.
Anthony mentioned that Split
APKs were
only introduced with Android
Lollipop.
You can mark -- single APK with
a specified module merged
together.
Now that we have covered how
dynamic features work, let me
hand it over to Ibo who will
show you how to create them.
>> IBRAHIM KARAHAN: Thanks,
Pierre.
To create a dynamic module all
you
need to do is download Android
3.
2 Canary and use the dynamic
feature Wizard included.
Click on the new module and file
menu.  Choose the dynamic
module.
While typing in the name,
Android
studio will create a new dynamic
module for you.  You can also do
the same thing manually by
editing the manifest and build
up Gradle files.
You start with the manifest of
your new module.  The first step
is to declare this module as a
new Split APK of your app.  To
do so, you are going to add the
split attribute in the manifest
tag and
give a name which is VR
underscore viewer in this
example.
The next step is to add a
module tag which is going to
declare a module and you are
going to give a title to the
module.
This tag is used by Play Store
to identify the modules of your
application.
Next you declare this module
as an on-demand module by adding
the on-demand attribute.
This means that this module is
only going to be delivered to
the user's device when the app
requests it from the Play Store
instead of  delivering it in
install time.
Of course, we now know that
dpoamed
modules are only available on N
plus devices.
If you choose to provide this to
pre-L devices you use the fusing
device to instruct Play Store to
include this
module along the module at
install time
or in the APK.
Start with the dike module.
The first thing, we are now
using a
new plug in called ...
the second thing is, we add the
base
module as dependency to this
module so that we can access the
functionality included in the
base module.
The will only change required in
the build out Gradle file of the
base module
is to add the dynamic features
list and put all the dynamic
module names into this replies
list.
This  instructs Gradle to make
the
resources in the base module
available to those modules.
Anthony will show you how to use
those
modules with the new Play Store
library.
>> ANTHONY MORRIS: Thanks, Ibo.
Take a look at how you request
on-demand modules to be
installed when you want them
installed.  In order to interact
with the Play
Store we are introducing a split
install pape as part of the play
call library.  This is a Java
client library that
communicates with the Play Store
via IPC on the device and the
Play Store
communicates with play servers
to download new modules when you
request them.  Take a look at
the code.  It is structured
using the sale task framework
you are probably familiar with
from the Google Play services
and API services on the.
This is a class called the split
install  manager.  You can
construct a request with all
the modules you wish to download
and invoke star install to
trigger the Play
Store to install the triggers
for those modules.
The API allows you to listen to
updates throughout the download
and install process.
You can use this to display
progress, download progress and
the install progress to your
users while they are waiting for
the on-demand features to
download.
You saw this in the video Pierre
showed when it was downloading
the recipe module.
For large modules you need to
obtain user information prior to
the download.
You need to do this whenever the
strow
the requests more than ten Meg
of requests to be downloaded.
However, there is an alternative
option for installing the
modules if
they are not used for immediate
use, deferred installation API.
If you use the simple one line
to request a deferred install of
a module,
then the module will be
downloaded at a convenient time
for the user.  This is generally
when the user is not using the
device and it is charging and on
WiFi.  Because of this we allow
you to
install larger modules via this
API without requiring user
confirmation, up to 100
megabytes.  This is a user
friendly way to
download large on-demand modules
for your app.
You can also use the split
install API to manage your
on-demand modules so you can see
which modules are currently
installed and if the user no
longer needs that module you can
request that it be uninstalled
freeing up space for your users
and reducing the footprint of
your app on their device.
Now, when you go and install an
on-demand module on N plus
devices the apps do not need to
be restarted.  The code is
available immediately upon the
install completing and new
resources and assets are
available once you refresh your
context object.
However, on Android L and M,
installing splits requires the
app to restart if you want to
install them properly.
But to avoid this we've included
a
split come Pat library which
emulates the install on L and M
until we can get to the
background and properly install
it.  This means that your app
doesn't need to restart and all
the things inside this, or
almost all the things inside
this module are immediately
available to your app.
You can set this split come Pat
library up similar to a multiDex
library in your apps.
Finally, when you release an
update to your app play will
automatically update both the
base module and any on-demand
modules that it already
installed.  So the versions of
your modules on a device are
always in sync, always at the
same version an partners tell us
this is something that they
really like about this model.
All right.  Let's wrap this
all up.
Starting today all the
developers can
build Android App Bundles in
Android 3.2 Canary and they will
be able to publish these on play
to all users.  I encourage all
of you to try this out and see
how much smaller wore app can be
by switching to the Android App
Bundle.  We will be rolling out
modularization to developers
over the coming months.
From today you can start
building modularized from the
studio to Canary
and publish them to the internal
and alpha tract.  And then to
beta over the comes months.  If
interested you can register your
interest in modularization at
the link provided.
And with that, thank you,
everyone, for coming.  If you
have any questions, you can grab
us afterwards.  I don't think we
have time right now.
Or you can grab us over the next
couple of days in the Sandbox C
behind the stage.
And thank you, have a great I/O.
(Applause.)
(Music playing.
)
(The session concluded.